- Can't believe
"manoeuvre" has an O in it.
Who decided that?
- What?
- Can't believe
"manoeuvre" has an O in it.
Who decided that?
- Manoeuvre!
- I'm still reeling over this.
- I've deadass never seen that.
- I stopped trying to learn
language a long time ago.
(chill music plays)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of "Trash Taste."
And this is, this is I'd
say a special one, right?
'Cause it's the last
episode you're gonna see
in this studio.
- Oh, Chris's thing fell as well.
- Oh.
Anyway.
- Anyway.
(everyone laughs)
- We definitely didn't script that bit.
- I'm your host for today, Garnt.
And with me are Joey and Connor.
And, yeah, boys.
How are you doing?
Sad to be moving out?
- A little.
A little sad.
- Just a very busy time right now.
- It is.
- We've got so much to
do with the new studio.
It's like, all right, we gotta record one
before we start the studio down.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- We're probably gonna
film a short little vlog
for "After Dark" as well,
which will hopefully be up by this time?
- It'll probably be out before this.
- So, go check out "After Dark."
- Yeah, 'cause I mean,
we are literally moving out tomorrow
after we film this today.
So, by the time this comes out,
this will probably be like
four, three, four weeks after.
- It still hasn't sunken in
that we're moving out tomorrow.
- It hasn't sunk in for me yet either.
- I'm just dreading
having to redo everything
and set everything up.
'Cause, you know, we have
a setup that works here
and everyone's like, "Why are you moving?
"Why are you moving?"
But you gotta mix it up.
You know, you gotta keep it fresh.
- Yeah.
- Also, you'll see why we want to move
if you watch the "After Dark" vlog
because we have no fucking space in here.
I'm glad that I don't have to, like,
I dread whenever I'm the host
'cause people don't know
the fucking obstacle course
you have to go around to
get to this host chair.
- I feel literally bad
for every guest that comes
to our show.
- Yeah, we do have a-
- Who has to like perform
parkour to get to their seat.
- A lot of tripping hazards and yeah,
Ladybeard nearly tested
the limits of our set
in multiple ways, not
just the shelf behind you,
but all the wires and stuff.
That man was too large and
in charge for those wires.
- I can't imagine how the
guest feels having to sit here
and having like,
what if you need to go
to the toilet, right?
'Cause the reason, okay,
the reason I hate going on flights
and sitting on the window
seat is I hate not being able
to access the toilet under my own will.
- Oh, I, dude, I know now
my limits of my own bladder.
So, now whenever I'm on a long
flight, I'm like, aisle seat.
Give me the aisle seat immediately.
I don't have to look at the view.
I've seen, I know what the
outside of a plane looks like.
- I know what sky looks like.
I don't need to look at sky.
I know what a city looks like from above.
- I will sacrifice, I will-
- All right, hold up.
Okay, this is gonna be
our first topic for fun.
Listen, okay, I am a firm window seat fan.
- Why?
- I'll tell you why.
Because, right.
What's the biggest downside of being
in the aisle, gentlemen?
What is it? Come on, there's gotta be one.
- Downside?
- There isn't.
That you don't see the view?
- There is one glaring
gigantic annoying issue,
and that is motherfucking
people in the window
and middle seat wanting to get out.
And God forbid, they're
fucking clumsy as shit
and they're like, "Oh!"
Like, fucking falling over everything,
and then they've got like 10 shit
that they got on their lap.
They got like the whole
fucking family buffet and shit.
They got like 10 headphones,
portable charger.
It's like, for fuck's sake,
put it in your fucking bag.
They're trying to shimmy around.
Like, get that shit away from
me. I want to go to the window
'cause I want to sleep and I
don't want to be disturbed.
- But you're okay with disturbing.
- Yeah, 'cause.
(everyone laughs)
That just shows like the
difference in mentality
'cause I would rather, I'm
fine with being disturbed.
I'm just like, "Go to the toilet, man.
"I know you need to."
- His voice with that, "I'm
fine with being disturbed."
Listen, I don't, okay.
I don't know if everyone else
sees it the same way as I do
'cause I know that I get
annoyed by minor things.
My house could burn down and I'll be like,
"That's fucking really
inconvenient, now isn't it?"
But someone moves in the
aisle seat, "For fuck's sake!"
- No, because for me
there's like a counter.
Like, because I know how much I piss.
I mean, I'm glad that
I don't need to worry
how much I piss on "Trash Taste"
'cause I piss a lot on "Trash Taste."
But in the confines of an
airplane, you are stuck there.
And you ask to go to the toilet once.
All right, that's reasonable, right?
Everyone has, everyone
knows everyone needs to go
to the toilet.
But twice.
Okay, that's kinda pushing it, you know?
What if I need to go three
times when everyone's sleeping?
What if that just happens?
- You're more worried
about pissing them off?
- Yeah, I'm more worried
about pissing them off.
- Picture it, you're on
the aisle, all right.
What is the limit before
you start to get annoyed
with how many times people
will get up to go and pee?
We're on a 12 hour flight.
- For me, it doesn't matter
because no matter what,
I'm gonna be pissing more than
these two people combined.
- For me, I never get pissed off
'cause I'm like, "I get it, man.
"I know the pain you're in.
"I know the trouble you're in.
"I got you, brother."
- That's my mentality, right?
The aisle people,
the aisle chumps are
used to being annoyed.
That's my theory, right?
So, I don't really feel bad
about disturbing in the aisle.
- I'm fucking zen on the aisle, you know?
- The middle seat you just lose.
I mean, they already knew they lost.
- The middle seat is just the loser seat.
No one ever wants to
sit in the middle seat.
I think that you're a fucking psychopath
if you actually choose to
sit in the middle seat.
- This is like, okay, well.
I mean, you know,
the only time I don't give
a about middle seat is
if we're on like an hour or two flight.
- Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
- Literally I watch one Jason
Statham movie and I'm there.
But, I mean, I do care
on a 12 hour flight.
But you've already lost at that point,
and you should have pre-booked.
That's your fault.
- Right, exactly.
- But do you ever do that
gamble where you're like,
"I want the whole row to myself.
"This plane looks just empty enough
"where I think I can pull this off."
And you're like,
"I'm gonna book just the middle seat
"in a clean row of three."
- No, I never.
- No.
- I do that.
I like to live life on the edge
'cause I know that,
what sick fuck is gonna
wanna sit next to a madman
that would willingly choose the aisle seat
in a row of three?
That should be like a danger sign.
- No, because what I do is
that I get the safe seat
of just an aisle seat 'cause
I know that no matter what,
even if that aisle was full,
I get the extra leg room.
I get immediate access to the toilet.
I don't disturb anybody.
It's a win win.
But then the moment I get
on the plane and I see, oh.
Not a lot of people waiting in
this waiting room right now.
Then that's when I go like,
"So how many aisles are open today?
"How many aisles? "Can I
sneak into one of those?"
And like I just ask,
and a lot of the times
they're just like, "Yeah."
- Yeah, but that's when it's empty.
That's when it's empty. And
also I don't ask, I just go.
- Oh, okay.
- The moment the plane, like,
the seatbelt things come on,
I'm like, "That's a free aisle.
"That's mine." I could see
other people on the plane.
I see their eyes looking
at the free seats.
I'm like, "No, it's mine."
(everyone laughs)
- "Out of the way!"
- "Get down!"
- Well, that's the other benefit of being
in the aisle, right?
You immediately just go "Go now!"
- But yeah, I mean, it's
rare that I'm on a plane
where it's like, where
there's an aisle there.
I'm pretty sure the
gamble you're making is
like fucking gacha odds, you know?
- I am talking about
when the plane is like,
basically like 70 to 80% full.
- Right, right, right, right.
- Because, again like I said, no one...
If you were on the
booking page of the plane,
you get to see the layout as you do,
you're not gonna sit next to the guy
who picked willingly the middle
because that's a bad sign.
I wouldn't do that.
If I saw someone in the middle, I'm like,
"He's a psychopath.
"That's a psychopath."
- He wants to "socialize" on the plane.
- Yeah, I'm like, no, no, no.
I'm not falling for this.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm not here to fucking socialize.
- I don't want to join a cult today.
I'm sure there'll be some cult.
But then I don't mind going on the,
okay, so, again I'll do that gamble.
If it doesn't work out, I might (laughs)
I might go to like
whoever's next to me like,
"You wanna swap?
"Wanna swap?"
- Do you actually?
- Yeah, sometimes.
I'm like, "Listen, I'm gonna sleep.
"Do you wanna swap?"
And then they're like, "Yeah."
- Wait, how easily do you sleep on planes?
'Cause I remember when I was like-
- With great difficulty.
- With great difficulty?
So like for me,
sleeping on the window seat
is actually less comfortable
than sleeping on the aisle seat as well.
Because-
- No, what?
- Because for some reason like you,
like, you know, your nature is, you know,
you can lean on the wall part, right?
But the wall of the plane is,
I don't know why it's just
tilted at such an angle
where you can never get a
comfortable leaning on that wall.
It's like, I don't know.
- This is why you bring a pillow.
- I don't know what engineer
designed it to make planes,
especially on the window seat,
the most uncomfortable
angle to lean your head by.
- Yeah, that is true.
- It is so weird because I have
no trouble sleeping on cars.
Cars, trains, any other
kind of moving vehicle,
I sleep like a fucking baby.
Put me on a plane, and I'm like insomnia.
Like, insomnia speed runner.
It's just...
- Well, I normally wear
a hoodie and a jacket
no matter what the weather.
I'll use them as padding.
- Yeah, because it also gets
fucking cold on the plane.
- Like, I need to be,
I need my head to be at
least like a 45 degree angle.
- That's called privilege.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Like, like, like-
- How does sleeping in the
aisle make this solution better?
- Because I can't tilt my
neck enough that it's like,
it's almost like horizontal.
- Here's how, I kind of
go like the wall is here
and the seat is here.
I kind of nestle into this corner.
Kind of like go in like this.
- 'Cause like for me, like I said,
my head needs to be like at
at least a 45 degree angle.
So not, you know, not my entire body,
but at least my head, you know?
So, it feels at least like I'm lying down
even though I wake up,
I get fucking neck cramps or whatever.
- Just go business.
(everyone laughs)
Like, at that point just go business.
- Honestly I have no
problem just sleeping,
like, I just put my head down
and just sleep on my arms on my lap.
- Oh, I can't do that.
- I can do that.
- I have attempted to do that as well.
- I'm too tall.
- [Garnt] That sounds like a
short person solution to me.
- This is what happens when
you're lower than 6', Garnt.
Just the world opens up to you.
It's like fucking origami.
- The 5'11" club over here.
(everyone laughs)
- Honestly every time I go on a plane,
I'm just like, "Damn, man,
I wish I was a bit shorter."
"I wish I was the 5'11" club."
- Fuck off.
"How's it feel to be short?"
- Well, that's the other benefit
to being in the aisle seat,
right, is that you can stick your legs out
and actually stretch them out.
- No, you can't.
- Yeah, you can.
- You can do 10 minutes
and the woman comes over,
she's like, "Hey, put
your fucking legs in."
Or the cart comes by, and
you're legs get fucking cut off.
- No, I'm like fucking right
up against the seat though,
so it just slides past.
- I don't know, I don't know, man.
- It's like a Jackie Chan film.
Just past.
- But I also, I don't
know if I can do this now
'cause it's been like two years
since I've been on a long flight.
- It's been awhile.
- It's been like two years,
but I used to stay up all night working,
and then my flight would be at like what?
Like, maybe mid day if I was lucky.
- Yeah.
- Maybe 8:00 AM if I was even luckier.
So, I'd stay up all night working,
and then right before I got on the plane,
I would just take one of
those over the counter,
really cheap week sleeping
pills you can get.
- The UK ones.
- Yeah, they're super, they're not-
- Like, melatonin?
- No, no, no.
Melatonin's the good shit.
That's illegal in the UK,
or you need a prescription
to get melatonin.
- Oh really?
- I think the one that you get
from the store is like
similar to hayfever medicine,
I think.
- Oh, like drowsy medicine.
- I swear to God, that's just sugar pills.
I swear to God.
- It doesn't actually do much,
but it's enough to like
kind of get your head going
and you're like, "All right,
I'm already sleep deprived.
"I stayed up all night working,
"and now I'm gonna go to bed."
'Cause like when I
would, when, what was it?
Two and a half years ago, maybe,
the last con season I
actually did before pandemic.
I went back and forth from
America like four times
in one month to the UK.
And the only way I could
do it was by sleeping.
- I just like,
if I need to sleep on a plane
and I don't have like melatonin
or like sleeping pills-
- I've never taken melatonin.
- I just go like, "Just give
me like two gin and tonics."
Just down that shit and zonk out.
- Alcohol doesn't work
on me to make me sleep.
I don't know.
- [Joey] Really?
- To me, I never drink alcohol on planes
because alcohol just makes the fluids run
through my body faster,
so I just gotta pee more.
So that just adds an extra
layer of stress for me
'cause I'm just like,
"Well, I gotta pee more
now I'm on this plane."
- I can not pee.
I can hold the pee.
- "I can not pee."
(everyone laughs)
- That's an out of context clip.
I can hold the pee for
like the whole 12 hours.
- You're a mad man.
- I unload before I get on the plane.
- "Unload!"
- I fully unleash it and I drink
minimal water on the plane.
- I'm pretty sure I unload
as much as I possibly can.
I go to pee like five times
before I get on the plane
and like, I sit down immediately-
- That's the problem.
You're peeing five times
before you get on the plane.
Your bladder already
sounds like it's failed you
before you even got to the
gate. I'm only peeing like once.
- Yeah, I don't know what it is though.
It's like a Pavlovian effect
where like the moment you hear the "ding"
of like the seatbelt sign, it's like,
"Oh fuck, I have to pee."
Every time.
- I mean, that's what I can hold it.
And I can sleep.
So, I'm like, I tell
the people next to me,
like if they seem nice.
If they don't seem nice,
I won't even say anything 'cause.
- Tell them what?
- I'll just be like,
"If the food comes, don't wake me up.
"I don't care about the food.
"Don't wake me up for anything."
- I thought you were
gonna say, "Don't worry.
"Don't worry if you have to pee
'cause I'm all for it, man."
(Joey laughs)
- 'Cause sometimes if you're gonna sleep
and they ask you, "Do you want food?"
And they think that you're
like actually like conked out
like completely, they might think like,
"Oh my God, he's like, he's
fainted," or something or like.
- No, I've just, if I'm on a plane-
- If you don't wake up.
If you don't wake up.
- Yeah, if I'm on a plane
and I'm asleep while the food goes past,
like I've never been woken up for food.
- Oh my God, I've had people
wake me up so many times.
- Really?
- I hate that actually.
- And I'm like, "Do you
know how hard I worked?"
- Exactly!
- For those five minutes.
I waited two hours to get to
sleep for five fucking minutes,
so you could wake me up?
This is why I also don't
want to sit in the fucking,
in the aisle because the
moment I fall asleep,
some person's gonna be like, "Excuse me.
"Can I go to the toilet?"
You literally waited.
You waited until I fell asleep.
Fucking piece of shit.
I hate you.
You're a scum of the earth.
I will watch the moment I see
them about to fall asleep,
I'm like, I'm gonna pee.
'Cause I'm like I wanna
give you some time.
- Like, there's only one
thing that annoys me more
about getting woken up just
to eat, you know, on a plane,
which I wasn't even
hungry in the first place,
and that is babies on a plane.
I don't know, man...
Crying babies on a plane just
triggers something in me, man.
I think it should be legally allowed-
- Do you have noise-canceling headphones?
- I don't.
- They're a lifesaver.
- Literally the, what are they called?
- Dude, I feel like a baby's
cry pierces any kind of-
- No, no, no, no.
Dude, those Sony WX 4,000,
whatever the fuck they are.
The stupidest name they
ever picked for them.
There's amazing
noise-canceling headphones.
You won't hear a fucking thing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause I've,
I don't know.
I don't usually use
noise-canceling headphones.
That might be my problem
because right now I'm just like,
I think it should be legally
allowed to punch babies
if they cry on a plane.
Like, that's, can we
all just agree on that?
- "Shut up!"
(everyone laughs)
- I feel like they might cry more, Garnt.
I don't know how the parents
would feel about this.
- You have to hit them just right.
- 'Cause it's like "Mad Max"
when the baby starts crying.
Parents are like fucking...
- All right man, problem solved.
- I never thought I needed-
(everyone laughs)
- Like, "Austin Powers" judo chop.
Judo chop!
(everyone laughs)
- My God.
I never thought I needed
noise-canceling headphones
until I had them.
And then I can't,
I literally go everywhere with them.
Like, you see me.
I do not go anywhere without
my noise-canceling headphones.
- I would only use
noise-canceling headphones
for the airplane.
- That's what you think.
- Okay, in what other like situations?
- It's so nice on the train
or any form of transport,
walking around, just getting isolated
and hearing your music and just the music.
And if you want, you can
hear some background noise.
It doesn't really matter.
- Dude, it's like living through an AMV.
It's fucking awesome.
- It's great.
I want to hear Philip DeFranco
when I'm walking downtown going,
"What's up, beautiful
bastards?" in my ear.
- Right in my, it's like ASMR.
- Right in my ear.
All I want to hear is Phil in my ear.
- I don't know.
I feel like I zone out enough as it is.
I don't need noise-canceling headphones.
(Joey laughs)
I'd literally just walk in
front of a truck or something
if I had noise-canceling headphones on.
- No, you kinda, you learn
to adapt. (everyone laughs)
- You become more wary.
- I look around a lot more now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which is a good thing.
- Kind of like Daredevil, right?
You take out one sense,
so you gotta compensate for
it with your other sense
or something.
- Just buy them.
You'll see, you'll see.
- Yeah, they're great.
- 'Cause I always thought
like expensive headphones,
I'm like, "I don't need more than 20 bucks
"or 50 bucks headphones.
"What a scam." And then I
bought them and I'm like,
"I'm such a fool.
"I was so wrong the whole time."
- The beeps and boops
sound even better now.
- Oh, they are amazing.
Changes everything.
- I did used to have like
really, really good headphones,
but they were just a real hassle.
- Beats by Dre.
(everyone laughs)
- They were just like a real
hassle to just lug around.
That's why I stopped using them.
- That's why mine, mine are like,
they fold into themselves.
Pretty easy to put in a
coat pocket or something.
- I just use the AirPods.
- Yeah, that's why I like
using like, you know,
earbuds whenever it's daily life.
If it's on a plane, yeah,
I'll bring the headphones.
- I wear the headphones everywhere.
- See like especially this time, like,
I don't mind the headphones either,
but like this time of year
when it gets hot as shit-
- Yeah.
- I hate having headphones around my neck.
- I need something to
distract me from the heat,
so I just blast some audio.
- So what?
Add more heat?
- Take one, take one-
- Add more insulation.
- Take one of the senses away from me,
so I can just go to another world.
I don't have to fuckin' pay
attention to Japan anymore.
- No, I hate that because
I start sweating here,
like on my ears, and then
when I take it off, it's like-
- Well, you have a lot of hair
though, so that might be why.
'Cause I don't really have like
that much hair around here.
(Joey laughs)
What?
I mean, that's probably it.
You're like muffling
all the hair in there.
You're like fucking making-
- I have to like fucking
like raise it up like this
to like hear anything.
- Garnt will be fine then.
- Yeah, you're good.
You two are fine.
- Yeah, we're fine.
- I'll be good, I'll be good.
(everyone laughs)
- Soon I'll have no hair
then they'll be no problem.
(everyone laughs)
- Then you'll just have
like a sunburn mark.
- Looking forward to getting
sunburned on your head, Connor?
- Just gonna become a hat guy.
(Garnt laughs)
Beanie guy.
- You already are starting
to become a hat guy.
Every time I see you in the summer.
- Oh yeah, 'cause I realized
that like it fucking hurts
to not wear a hat.
- It hurts?
- The sun hurts so much.
I think that's what the biggest
thing that changed to me.
I was walking today to
the train and I was like,
when did I just like hate seeing the sun?
Like, when did that happen?
'Cause I remember I
didn't mind being outside.
But now I hate the
thought of having the sun
on my skin at all.
- Sounds like the most British thing
I've ever heard honestly.
- I didn't used to be this way.
I don't know what happened!
- "I just hate the sun."
- Literally-
- Wait, can you tan?
- No, I just burn.
- Right.
- But now I actually like, if
I stay in the sun too long,
I feel like nauseous real fast
without like a hat or anything.
Yeah.
- I feel that's like a different-
- Is it just because it's too hot?
- I think maybe here, yeah.
I think it's just way
harder than I'm used to.
- It's also because of
the humidity, right?
- Yeah, the humidity.
- I feel like you're just,
it's more, it's not the sun.
It's just the heat because-
- It's both, it's both.
- In like England, the sun
fucking tickles you, you know?
You don't feel anything.
- It's like, I feel like
they play off each other.
So, the sun makes the humidity worse,
then the humidity makes the sun worse.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Because when the sun's beaming on you
in like LA or whatever, it's not too bad.
Obviously I don't wanna stand-
- Really?
It hurts.
- I don't know about that.
I don't know.
- It hurts.
I'm not saying it's great,
but I mean, it's better
than it is in Japan
just 'cause the humidity
makes it feel 10 times worse.
- I mean-
- I don't know if there's
some like ray bullshit,
like mimic, like, you know,
going in the water droplets
in the air fucking,
the frogs they're making the-
(everyone laughs)
I don't know if there's
some shit going on there.
I don't know.
- Some conspiracy theory shit.
- I don't know.
There's probably someone smarter than me
who can figure it out.
- It's honestly, I think it's
just like a preference thing,
right?
Like, some people are like,
"Yeah, humidity's whatever."
And then there are others who are like,
"Oh yeah, my skin is
like physically burning."
- I like a little bit of humidity.
Japanese humidity is like way too much.
- Yeah.
- Last summer I could like
only survive by going around
with like a fucking UV umbrella.
Felt like an old woman.
- Yeah, that's right.
- I felt like an old woman.
I would just go around with
like this foldable umbrella
that I would just go around.
I'd be like, "Don't talk to me."
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I can't.
- The first time I saw you
with that, I thought...
I was like, "Are you waiting
for me to like say a joke or?"
- Because I realized it's not enough
to just protect my head.
- "Is this a bit?"
- It started, like, even
the hat didn't really help
that much, and I needed
to cover like my neck
and like my arms and shoulders.
- You need to get those like visors that-
- I'm one, yeah, I'm one step away
from being the old
woman at the supermarket
because they wear like sleeves.
Like, shade sleeves and
like a full like neck thing
for the sun.
- Shout out to those of us
who've never been sunburned
in our lives.
Is this a white man problem
that I just don't get?
- I think so.
I think I'm aging rapidly.
- Imagine sunburning.
- Imagine sunburning, oh God.
Imagine being hurt by this
natural occurring thing
that's existed since the
beginning of our planet.
- I feel like my body didn't age
and then it decided that
everything would just kick
into overdrive and start aging
rapidly from age like 23.
I don't know what happened.
We went to Japan and it
just made me feel old.
I don't know why.
So now-
- Literally the youngest man in the room.
- My UV umbrella broke and shit.
It snapped.
- It broke?
- It broke. I don't know how it broke.
- Did the sun snap it?
- I don't know.
- The rays were too heavy.
- I like to-
- How did it break?
- How the fuck did it break?
- You know when you pull it out?
'Cause it was one of the foldable ones.
So, you can fit it into a small bag.
It just like when I
pulled it out one time,
it just fucking came off.
And I was like, "Oh."
- I guess no sun protection
for the day then.
- No, so now I need to buy a new one.
I've been looking on Amazon,
but one hasn't caught my
fancy yet, so we'll see.
(Joey laughs)
I'm very picky.
- Is this a fashion statement
or something as well?
- No, I just wanted one that
wouldn't break, you know?
'Cause I've been burned once,
twice now, from the sun
and from the umbrella.
- Just buy a more sturdy one surely.
- Oh thanks, Garnt.
- It's an umbrella!
It's a fucking,
it's a fucking umbrella.
How wrong can an umbrella be?
Does it protect you?
Does it give you shade?
That's all it needs to do surely.
- Well, I mean, you know, 'cause-
- Then why the fuck you
worried about like the design?
- 'Cause I already look
like a clown using it.
I want to at least not make
it too bad and get like a,
if I get a pink one, it'd look pretty bad.
So, I want to try and get like somewhat-
- Nothing wrong with pink.
- Yeah.
- I could rock it.
I just don't want to have to
justify why I'm rocking it.
You know what I mean?
- Why are you like
trying to prove a point?
- I could own it.
I just don't want to.
(everyone laughs)
I have no qualms with
having a pink umbrella
if that's what you're wondering.
- That was the most like
roundabout way of saying,
"Yes, but also no."
- I'll get a pink umbrella, fine.
I'll buy a pink umbrella.
- Yeah, get it.
Do it for the bit.
- Fine, fine.
No one's gonna see it.
It's literally-
- We'll put it on Twitter, don't worry.
- It's for the bit.
My daily life.
My daily life is a joke.
- We'll put it on the Twitter.
Don't worry.
(everyone laughs)
Subreddit will go ham
on that, don't worry.
- Let's fucking talk
about something serious.
(everyone laughs)
(Connor speaks Japanese)
(Garnt speaks Japanese)
(Joey speaks Japanese)
- Shut the fuck up, Joey.
(Garnt laughs)
- All right, let's not do that.
Bokksu even partners with
Japanese artisan makers
to make sure you're
getting authentic flavors,
and Bokksu snacks are
different every month
and have different themes.
Hey Connor, open up the box
to show us what's inside!
- Oh, I certainly will, Joey.
As you can see here, this
month's theme is summer fruits.
(Connor speaks Japanese)
(Joey gasps)
- Everything in this
box is fresh and fruity.
We've got lemon flavored.
(Joey speaks Japanese)
Fried rice crackers and peanuts,
and many, many more.
- [Garnt] The snacks come with
an organic (speaks Japanese)
tea pairing as well.
- So, if you want to get
your hands on the snacks
that hit different, use
our code TrashTaste20
to get 20% off your own Bokksu today.
This offer is only valid for June,
and repeat customers will
get a themed box every month.
(Connor speaks Japanese)
(Joey speaks Japanese)
- Back to the episode.
- Fuck you, Joey.
- Script reading, big brain.
- Oh my God, yeah.
So, I don't know.
- Well, in other news,
there's something happened.
- There is something less light-hearted
and more serious that
has happened recently.
- I was trying to find
a little like downtime
before we go onto that.
I guess we'll go straight into it.
- Let's just go straight
into depression, so...
How can we say this, boys?
One of the greatest manga artists-
- One of my fucking heroes just died.
- One of the greatest
manga artists of all time
just passed away recently.
- Old news by the time this comes out.
- By the time this comes out,
this will be like a month old news now.
But yeah, Kentaro Miura, author
of "Berserk" has passed away
and-
- Age 54, right?
- Yeah, age 54.
Of like, what did he die of?
- I forgot the scientific name of it,
but it's like one of
his like main arteries
in his heart just like exploded.
- Fuck.
- Essentially.
So basically it's a heart attack.
Yeah, but yeah, it's a
fucking horrible way to die.
- I'll tell you honestly,
after hearing about this news,
I'm never gonna make fun
of a hiatus ever again.
- Yeah, honestly.
(Connor laughs)
No, like legit.
Like, it's scary, man.
Like, because...
Yeah, because, you know,
obviously no one really knew
as to why he was on hiatus, right?
- Yeah, no one knew.
- They normally don't
usually give reasons.
They just like-
- People are extremely versatile.
- "He/she is on hiatus,
just deal with it."
But, yeah, apparently, I guess.
I don't know.
Was he sick or was it
just completely sudden?
- I don't know.
At the time of recording,
I haven't read enough about what happened
to know if it was like a
reoccurring health problem
or if it was just a sudden thing.
But man, like we all know
how much pressure manga
artists get put through anyway
and how much work they have
to do on a weekly basis.
I mean, it's crazy to think
that most of the big manga
artists we know about,
you know, working shonen jump or whatever,
get like two weeks off.
No, less than two weeks
off every year, right?
- It's like golden week and
then like one extra week.
- I doubt they take it as
well. I doubt they take it.
- And they don't really, I
doubt they take it off as well.
It's just one week where they are forced
to take a break, right?
- I mean, I wasn't too
familiar with "Berserk."
I'd only watched the 90s anime.
- That's familiar enough.
- I really enjoyed.
It was very good.
- It's great.
- Fuck, I mean,
it's just kind of sad hearing
like a legend of the industry
who's kind of influenced a
lot of things that we've done.
- Yeah.
'Cause I remember we were
filming another project
when the news broke to us,
and it didn't hit me immediately
because I was in like work
mode, I was in filming mode,
so I was like, "Okay, I
gotta do this, this, this."
And then it got home,
listened to Guts' theme once,
and it just played continuously
for like the entire night.
And I'm just sitting
there just like fucking,
like part of my soul had died.
- Yeah, I literally went
home and I was like,
"I'm gonna reread 'Berserk.'"
- Yeah, I feel like everyone did.
- I started reading it.
- I couldn't get past volume
one without feeling like,
this fucking wave of like, oh fuck.
- Yeah, 'cause like I always know
that "Berserk" is one
of the greatest manga
that has ever been made.
And then going back home and realizing,
just remembering everything
that was in this story
and in this manga, it just
hit even fucking harder
because I just had
forgotten how good it was
before I really took the time to remember
what it had achieved and
some of its greatest moments.
If you hadn't read "Berserk,"
there's always a perfect
time to read "Berserk"
because anytime is the perfect
time to read "Berserk."
So, please read fucking "Berserk."
It's amazing.
- I mean the manga single-handedly
inspired the Dark Souls series.
- I mean, it inspired a lot.
It wasn't just Dark Souls.
A lot of things wouldn't exist right now
if not for "Berserk."
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- And I don't know what
it is about "Berserk,"
but it's literally like,
it's literally the one
show, or not even one show,
the one story or the one manga
that seems to be like no matter
how tough this person is,
no matter how like detached
they are from the world
or whatever, "Berserk"
seems to be that one story
that seems to be able to
affect anyone who reads it.
- Yeah, because like
fundamentally, you know,
it's like this whole
like dark fantasy thing
with these like mythical creatures
and it's bloody, gory and, you know, epic.
But like the main themes
mostly are just like,
you know, one person trying to figure out
what the fuck they want to do in life.
And like that's a theme
that literally anyone
can get behind, right?
Like, I'm kind of in this world,
shit's happening around me,
I don't really know what
my purpose is in life.
- I forgot how brutal it was.
- It's brutal.
- Again, I watched all the 90s anime.
And I was like, holy shit.
- The 90s anime is brutal as fuck.
- I was like, "What the fuck?"
I was like, "Oh my God."
Like, it's just like, fuck.
It just hurts to read.
- [Garnt] It does.
- It's so uncomfortable at times.
- Yeah, and I think it's incredible
because it is really,
really fucking brutal.
There are some like,
like his art, obviously we
haven't talked about his art yet.
It's like some of the
best art to ever exist
in the world of manga.
Like, some of the horrific
imagery he managed to conjure up
and some of like the creature designs
and everything were
just something straight
out of a nightmare, you know?
And it's a brutal show and
it's an action packed show
as well.
Guts is like one of the biggest
badasses in anime and manga.
And yet having said all that,
the moments that people remember are
like the really intimate moments,
which isn't what you think
if you looked at "Berserk"
on a surface level, right?
You look at "Berserk" you
see these horrific creatures,
you see Guts with a massive
sword tearing shit up,
and you're like, "Yeah!
"This is a manly man show."
And you read it and you're
just like fucking crying inside
because, you know, you see,
trying to see Guts like
get through his trauma
and find his journey and
everything like that.
It's like, it's the real intimate moments
that always stand out,
and it's the real serene
moments that always stand out.
And I think that's what
really sets "Berserk" apart
from like so many other series
where it's the serene moments juxtaposed
against all like the horrific moments
that make it one of, to me,
like it's one of my
favorite pieces of fiction
that's ever been made.
I got reminded of that
after remembering everything
that "Berserk" did.
- It's like if the fucking
Doom guy had like a wife
and family and he just
went home sometimes.
(everyone laughs)
You get reminded like,
"Oh shit, this is a guy."
Because when you're-
- Doom guy's like, "Why
am I killing these?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"What is my purpose?"
(everyone laughs)
I was really, I, you know,
'cause I don't know why
someone compared it on Twitter.
I thought, I guess so,
but then I read "Berserk."
I'm like, no, no, no.
But it is kind of like, you do forget
'cause sometimes like you're reading it,
you're like, this is like so Doom-esque
where he's just literally
just beheading horses.
You're like, "Oh, this is like Doom."
And then it's like really
sad and you're like,
"This isn't like Doom."
(everyone laughs)
- It's literally that meme
where the girls were like,
"I can't believe he
didn't cry during Titanic.
"Do boys even have feelings?"
And then like there's just the
boys crying over Guts' theme,
which was literally what
I was doing that night.
Just Guts' theme was playing
and I was just like crying in bed.
Just like, oh my God.
- Yeah, I dunno.
It's just, yeah.
Like, every time I re-read it,
it's just because. you know,
every time a new volume came out
'cause it was so much time
in between like the later volumes,
I was like, "Well, fuck.
"I guess I have to read
it from scratch again."
And so I would keep reading
it from scratch over
and over again.
And it's one of those
shows where I'm just like,
how does this not get like stale?
Because I probably read it,
like the first 30 volumes,
probably like a good,
like maybe 10, 20 times.
I'm just like, how does this
keep just getting better?
Like, how do I keep
finding new things in this?
- I mean, you guys know me.
I don't fucking rewatch anything.
I refuse to rewatch.
But even just rereading the first,
what is the first one called?
- "The Golden Age."
- "The Golden Age," that.
Just rereading that again, I'm like,
"Holy shit, this was so good."
- Yeah.
- Like, even though I've seen
this, I've read it earlier.
Like, I tried to read it again
ages ago for some reason now-
- Sometimes when I'm bored,
I just like go to the eclipse
arc and just look at the art.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, how can one
person think of this?
- Yeah, I know.
- It's just insane.
- And you know-
- And the dude was like 15 as well
when he like first came up
with the concept of the zone.
- Did you see the manga
he made before "Berserk"
when he was actually 15?
- He was like 15 or 16.
- It's better than most
modern manga artists.
- I'm like, this is not the
art skill of a 15-year-old.
- Exactly, exactly.
And like he paired that talent
and he just kept improving
on it to the point
where literally, I dunno,
there's only like a few people
in the world who I think
can even match, you know,
the talent that he puts
into the panels that he did.
- I mean, I saw this like
really interesting interview
with him like after, you
know, his death was announced
where like apparently
one of the big reasons
as to why he was on hiatus was
because he got so infatuated
with detail that it would
literally get to the point
where he would zoom in
and like actually edit
every fucking pixel.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- And like he-
- Sounds like a prison, that's perfection.
- Yeah, and he kept, you know,
getting like on hiatus
over and over again.
And his, you know, editors would be like,
"You can't even see this detail on paper.
"So like just stop."
And he was just like, "No.
"I have to get this right.
"I have to get this perfect."
- Honestly, like some of
the panels he's done belongs
in a museum, you know?
'Cause like the reason for that is
'cause I just remember like
that night when I went back,
I just like went to look
at some of the panels
and I just remember staring
at them for such a long time
because you know when
you're reading a story,
sometimes, you know, you
wanna see what happens next.
So you don't read it.
You don't appreciate the art at the moment
when you first read it.
But I went back to look
at some of the panels,
and I just, the amount of
work and amount of detail
and the amount of vision that was put
into these panels were fucking amazing.
I did not appreciate
it fully the first time
even though I could
tell these were amazing.
I didn't take the time to fully appreciate
how fucking amazing
some of these panels are
'cause they are incredible.
- [Joey] 100%.
- They, you know, they are
just basically the same
as any other painting or any other art.
- I really want to know if they have
like a "Berserk" art book of some kind
because I would fucking purchase
that in a heartbeat, dude.
- I can imagine
that they'll probably end
up doing something soon
to celebrate the legacy.
- I hope they do like open
up an exhibit or something.
'Cause that would be absolutely amazing
'cause if there's one, you know, one manga
that deserves an exhibit,
that deserves the artwork
to be plastered on the wall.
- It's Miura, yeah.
- It's fucking "Berserk."
- Yeah, 100%.
- It was kind of sad to see
that a lot of people were
just like, "Well, what's
gonna happen to the story?"
And it's like-
- Those aren't fans of "Berserk."
- It's frustrating
'cause when I saw the
announcement on Twitter
there were so many people being like,
"Does this mean it's not gonna finish?"
- It's like, yes, no shit.
- To me, it's just so, it's like,
how about you just give
them a chance to like grieve
before you ask these questions.
- If anything I'm kind of-
- The answer's probably gonna be no.
- Because there were a lot
of people as well being like,
"Oh, but you know,
"they can probably just
get like Miura's assistants
"to finish it."
And like, no, no.
I would rather it just be where it is.
Just end it.
- I'm fine with it being
an unfinished masterpiece,
you know?
That's fine.
That's fine for me.
It's "Berserk"-
- Was it realistically ever
gonna finish, do you think?
- I mean, I don't think,
like, not a single one
of like the, you know,
the Kings were killed.
I think only one of them was killed.
- [Garnt] I think one of them was.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, there was a long, long way to go.
- We were so early in the story
and the pace that the
story was progressing,
I doubt it would have finished
in our lifetime or, you know,
I think it was always
going to be unfinished.
But I think "Berserk" has
already achieved enough
that it doesn't need to be finished.
- Yeah, it was like what I said
when we talked about last time
we spoke about reading manga
where I just get to,
I often get to a point when
I'm reading manga I'm like,
"I'm satisfied.
"I genuinely, it'd be
cool if this ends nicely,
"but I've read up to a point
"where I feel like I'm happy
with what I've been given."
And I feel like "Berserk"
has definitely done that.
- There's been plenty
of moments in "Berserk"
that have felt like a resolution moment,
like a big resolution moment.
Even though not every
plot detail was resolved,
even though not every
loose end was tied up,
I feel like it's resolved
enough in my heart
to make it like impact me
this much already, you know?
And I think "Berserk," you know,
the journey of Guts is already
amazing enough as it is.
And some journeys, you know,
some journeys don't need
to come to an end on paper,
you know?
I've seen enough of the
journey where I'm satisfied.
It's...
- Just knowing that he's
out there somewhere still.
Looking for the end, right?
- Exactly.
- With the biggest fucking sword.
(everyone laughs)
- Fat fucking sword.
- Yeah, honestly I don't
know what else to say.
It was just, it's a story
that has impacted me.
- If there's anything we can say
on this "Trash Taste" episode,
it's please go read "Berserk."
Give it a go.
- Pay respect to the king.
- Yeah.
- Honestly.
- Honestly, he is a king.
- He's the fucking GOAT, man.
- I hope, you know, if we find
out more about the details
of, you know, what might've
caused his early death,
that if it is something to
do with being overworked
or anything, the lifestyle,
that I hope it does
make a change, if it is.
We don't know that, obviously.
We might never know.
But if we do find out more details,
and it becomes publicly
available, and we, you know,
we know that maybe being overworked is-
- Yeah, I think it would be
good to at least, you know,
kind of put into the public discussion.
- Because, you know, even if you are,
you know, you have, 'cause
normally with heart problems
and this kind of blood stuff,
it's normally there is some
hereditary stuff at play.
But I mean still at 54 is young.
Like, that...
Lifestyle would have to have an effect.
- I think so.
- I just want mangas to
not have so much stress
on their body where it fails, you know?
I don't know.
I feel bad, man.
It makes me feel shitty.
- Yeah, I mean, it sucks
because like, you know,
there's not really much I can add to that
because manga artists work a hell of a-
- We know, we know-
- We know they work way too hard.
- Whether voluntarily or not,
the deadlines that they set themselves
or are set on them are too much.
And it doesn't help that
fans are so demanding.
And that for some fucking reason,
the first question that some fans have
when an author dies is
what happens to the story.
It's like, I mean, it feels so selfish,
and it feels, you know,
because we as fans also have
something where we're selfish.
- Yeah, yeah.
I don't know, like
surprisingly, from what I saw,
there weren't as many of those comments.
- It wasn't that bad.
It just sours your taste
when you see even one.
- Every now and then
I saw it and I'm like,
"Okay, clearly you don't
really give a shit."
- I mean, none of them said offensive.
- There were just some
of the insensitive ones.
- It reminds me of a-
- But it's like when there's
earthquakes and stuff, right,
but people are always just like,
"Oh, the manga it's delayed
'cause of an earthquake?"
And it's like, what do you mean?
Like, people like people die.
- Exactly.
- Like, earthquakes are no fucking joke.
And it's like the people
that most, I mean, you know,
obviously with this situation
is very sensitive, you know,
and it was very fresh
and a lot of people care.
But I noticed, especially with
like earthquakes and stuff,
that people are very quick to be like,
"Oh, who gives a shit?
"It's just an earthquake."
- "It happens all the time."
- And it's like,
I think it plays into
the overall sentiment
of that a lot of anime fans
and manga fans are very
demanding for the stuff
that they want.
And I feel like we as fans
need to chill out a little bit.
- Yeah, they care about the product,
but not so much about
the person making it.
- Yeah, I feel like we as fans
generally need to chill out
about our passion for anime and manga.
- I'd say that.
- External things happen.
They happen.
It is what it is.
- Remember that some actual
person is making your product.
- Whether it be an earthquake
or personal stress,
they're all valid reasons
for work to be delayed.
- Give them some respect.
- I just want creators to
be able to create the shit
to the best of their ability
and not have to worry.
I hope that's not
controversial for me to say.
- What a hot take!
- I don't know.
- Respect staff members.
- I don't know, I just feel
like when you say this shit-
- There's people behind the work.
I mean, I'm sure everyone can agree on it.
It's just more, you know,
I'm sure 99% of people
watching this don't do that.
It's just that 1%.
It's always that 1%.
'Cause I remember,
this reminds me of like
the "Game of Thrones" thing
with JRR Martin where I remember
like seeing an interview
with him and he said that he got annoyed
that some people were
worried about his health
not because they were
worried about his health,
but they're worried if he would be alive
to finish "Game of Thrones."
And I'm just like, yeah,
that's pretty fucked up
that like fans are saying
that to you, aren't they.
- Jesus Christ.
- And even if they didn't say it,
I'm sure he knows that people
are probably thinking it.
- Yeah, he can read between the lines.
- People only care about his well-being
in terms of the book.
Like, he's being fucking
held hostage by the story.
Like, you know what I mean?
You can't fucking do anything.
- If anyone knows the intention
of "Game of Thrones" fans,
it's the guy who made "Game of Thrones."
(everyone laughs)
- It's just sad, it's just sad.
I don't know.
Like, this makes me sad for
like many reasons, you know?
There's just so much at play.
- This is well, I mean, it's
a sad topic unfortunately.
- It's all about the respect.
That's all it is.
Respect the creators, respect the artists.
Give them some space
if they're feeling sick
or need a break.
- Yeah.
Moving on to lighter topics though.
I heard you've been watching
anime recently, Connor.
- Kinda yeah.
- Which is a rare feat.
- I remember I used to do that.
(everyone laughs)
- The anime man.
What happened?
- Did you guys watch
"Castlevania," the new season?
- I have not.
- Not season four.
- Bro, it's so-
- But we haven't talked about
"Castlevania" yet, have we?
- It's so good, it's so good.
- I mean with how,
I mean, I've watched up to season three.
If there's one anime I have
like kind of caught up to,
it's "Castlevania."
But like-
- Where did you get up
to in "Castlevania?"
- I got up to season three.
So, I haven't finished season three.
I'm about halfway through season three.
But I mean, it's just been for me,
it's been getting better
and better every season
as it's been going on
and I just haven't had
time to binge it yet.
So...
- I don't know, man.
Everything about that anime,
especially the past season,
just blew it out the water.
- What's so good about it?
- Like, I feel like
everything that was good
in previous seasons was
at its best this season.
- Really?
- The story was the best.
The animation was just insane.
Like, some of the fights.
Even though in season three,
the fights like the
final fight was so good.
- Even season one had
some crazy animation.
- It just feels like
they've stepped it up.
Like again, like I think
one of the strongest points
of "Castlevania" has
been the voice acting.
The English voice acting-
- The English voice acting is fantastic.
- Insane.
- It's fantastic.
- Like, the fact that they
have like all the accents
on point, none of the accents feel silly.
Every single accent
that the characters have
it feels genuine.
Every single British accent is on point.
And it's like, holy shit.
How do they do this?
This never happens in anime.
How did they get an actual accent?
- It's like they hired British actors.
- I love the fact that
for example the JoJo
in the dub like tried to do the accent,
but I wish they'd got the native people.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because like in "JoJo Part One,"
it's Johnny Yong Bosch
doing in a British accent,
which isn't bad.
- Yeah, it is.
- Which isn't bad.
But I know there's no
shortage of native English,
British accents that can work in LA.
You know, like...
- It feels like the
voice actors they hired
for "Castlevania" were
just outside of your
usual anime voice actors.
- They were just general actors.
- Yeah, they felt like general actors
that would act in like a TV series
or like a live action movie.
- Well, yeah, because they have like,
they have such a good
variation of British accents.
Like, they have like the whole spectrum,
and they've chosen it like the
character's given the accent
based very specifically on like
what it would be in the UK.
Like, where you were born, your wealth,
your socioeconomic background.
It sounds like, it's so stupid,
but it fits every single character.
And it's just insane 'cause I mean,
we can't appreciate, I mean,
we can't appreciate
that in the Japanese one
where they might get
regional accents on point
within their own show.
Sometimes you get like the subtitles
where they're supposed to be
a bit more like Osaka dialect
or a bit rough.
But I can't really appreciate that.
- Honestly I've been appreciating
Japanese voice acting
a lot more recently.
- Yeah.
- Because I've actually
started to watch anime
without subtitles on.
So, I'm like properly
forced to like listen.
- Wow, you are like
level 100 weeb right now.
- Oh yeah, exactly.
(everyone laughs)
- You're at the final
stage before you graduate.
- Exactly, exactly.
- The final test.
- So, I'm like trying to
pick up more of my Japanese,
and part of the exercise I've
been putting myself through is
like everything I watch
now, not subtitled.
Like, my enjoyment has
definitely of anime gone down,
but it's like-
- It helps.
- It helps so much more.
It's a night and day
watching with subtitles on
and without subtitles on.
- When you don't understand
something that's being said,
how do you, do you go back and
turn the subtitles on then?
- Yeah, so normally I watch
anime on Crunchyroll or Netflix.
So Crunchyroll will have the opportunity
to select no subtitles, so
I can select no subtitles.
If there's something that I
really, really want to know
what they said, I just rewind
a bit, turn on subtitles.
"Oh, okay, that's what he said."
And then move on.
Same thing with Netflix as well.
I mean, it turns anime
to not just like a passive watching thing
and you're just like actively watching-
- Study material.
- Yeah, it is study material.
But if you're gonna have study material,
at least have study
material you can enjoy.
- [Connor] True, true, true, true.
- It's just a different
kind of watching in my eyes.
But since then, I, like,
I remember recently I've
been watching "Nagatoro"
without subtitles,
and I had like my first emotional response
to watching an anime
without having subtitles on.
It just, it felt nice
'cause I'm just like,
"I get what's going on.
"I'm getting emotionally invested."
- "Is this what these
Japanese people feel like?"
- Yeah, that's exactly what I felt!
It's like, "Oh, I'm
feeling some stuff now.
"Is this how the Japanese people feel?"
I'm not reading the subtitles
and getting feelings.
I'm actually hearing it.
- Actually listening to it.
- I don't know how to quite describe it
because it was a new feeling for me.
- Well, Garnt, I do the
same thing just with hentai
because they don't have
subtitles most of the time,
so I just watch it.
- Fair enough.
- I feel big brain when
I (speaks Japanese)
(everyone laughs)
- I got that one.
I understand that.
- I'm kidding.
I understand most of it actually.
Just feels weird that
I'm doing it with hentai
and not fucking anime!
- I have actually learned
one word from hentai
and that was naka.
I remember going through
my Japanese classes,
and like I was like, oh,
so naka means inside.
And I was like, "Where have
I heard the term naka?"
Yeah, inside.
"Oh, that's where I've heard that before."
(everyone laughs)
- That's a word you'll hear quite often
in many different contexts.
- That's the word I've learned from hentai
that I can also use in daily life.
- I can already see the
meme. It's like the fucking,
Garnt drinking with the fucking coffee,
watching anime with no subtitles,
watching hentai with no subtitles.
(everyone laughs)
I can already see the meme.
But I mean, yeah, sorry.
Yeah, the voice acting is
just fucking stellar, man.
If every voice acting
was like "Castlevania,"
we would only be watching dubbed anime.
- Do you think it played
a massive part to,
I assume it's a big part of
it is because it was dubbed
first in English rather than-
- 100%, 100%.
- Rather than dubbed
from Japanese to English.
- Is there a Japanese dub for it?
- I'm pretty sure there must be.
- I've never seen it in Japanese.
I don't know if I'll be able to watch it.
- When you watch the dub,
it's so Goddamn good.
It's actually a shame to watch
it in any other language.
- Yeah.
- Maybe this is how Japanese people feel.
We don't have a choice.
But when we have a choice,
why would you, you know, pick
the one that is best, right?
This is definitely one of
those shows where I'm like,
it's not even a competition.
- Because like-
- But then obviously it was, yeah.
- Yeah, because when I watched season one,
I was like, all right, well,
the default is in English
because it's an English production.
I'll watch episode one.
"If the voice acting is kind of subpar,
"then whatever, I'll change it."
But, literally first
five minutes, I was like.
"All right, English it is then."
It's fantastic.
- It's like an anime that is written
with kind of pretty fucking good American,
I would say it's American writers, right?
So, I feel like it's a
lot easier for the actors
to act the script.
- 'Cause the dialogue is like
very witty and sarcastic.
- Fucking funny.
- Because you hear the dialogue,
and it doesn't feel like anime dialogue.
- It's so fucking funny.
It's good.
- Very, very witty and like facetious.
- Oh shit.
Oh, okay.
- It's just like, it's so
rare to find an anime dub
where people actually swear.
Like, I can count them on one hand.
- "For fuck's sake."
- When someone says fuck
or shit, I'm like, "Oh!
"Oh, this dub's going hard."
- "We not in Japan anymore."
(everyone laughs)
- I love it, I love it.
- Yeah, so like hearing it
just like said so naturally,
you know, like talk to any
other Brit or Aussie, you know,
it's something that's like
just ingrained into our speech.
If you listen to "Trash Taste,"
you fucking know that.
- It's great too because
it doesn't feel forced.
- Oh no, no.
- Because there's a lot of
times where they're like,
we're going to be a little
explicit just to, you know,
be like, ooh, edgy and everything.
But like in "Castlevania," it's like,
yeah, I can imagine that.
They would totally say that.
- 'Cause like when you hear it in an anime
or like an anime video game,
'cause I remember the most
recent example I can think
of is playing Persona 5 dubbed
and hearing Ryuji say shit,
I'm just like, "Ryuji,
wash your mouth, sir!"
- "You are but a child!"
- "Excuse me!"
- When Trevor Belmont's
like, "Oh, for fuck's sake,"
you're like, "Oh, that's nice.
"Say it again.
"Say it again louder."
- Say it again.
(everyone laughs)
- It's so good, dude.
I fucking, like everything
about that I feel like,
even though it gets a lot of good,
people say it's very good,
I feel like it should be
way bigger than it is.
It's genuinely like one
of my favorite animes
that I've watched in
like the past like year.
- I would agree with that.
- It's really up there.
- It's really, yeah, it's up there.
- I can't wait 'til you
watch season four fully.
- I really need to.
- You're gonna be like,
"All right, okay, hold on."
- I mean, for me right now,
it doesn't even feel
like an anime, you know?
It's an American
production, obviously, but-
- It's kind of like-
- We're about to get into that topic.
- It feels in the same area as "Avatar."
- "Avatar," yeah.
- I also consider "Avatar" anime.
I mean, Japanese people
consider it anime, it's anime.
Like, who gives a fuck?
- I did not consider it anime
until I actually watched all of "Avatar"
and I'm like, okay, I can see
where this argument never ends.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
we're getting into semantics, you know.
It's whatever because the
only thing I will say is that-
- Anime or not, it's fantastic.
- Yeah, anime or not, it's fantastic.
But I don't give a shit if you
think it's an anime or not.
It's just a fantastic show in general.
All I was trying to say is
like, I don't think people,
more people in the anime
community are talking about it.
It's just 'cause it feels different.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Let me give you an anecdotal story.
I was talking to a guy and
I asked him, I was like,
"Oh, what animes do you like?"
And he goes, "One anime
that I watched recently
"that I really liked," this
is all in Japanese, like,
"I recently watched 'Despicable Me 2.'
"It was one of my favorite
animes of recent."
And I was like...
That completely-
- Hold up.
- It made me realign this
whole argument of like,
is this anime, is this not?
I'm like, listen, this guy deadass,
this Otaku, self-proclaimed
Otaku just told me,
"Despicable Me" is a good anime.
I'm like, you know what,
why are we arguing?
(everyone laughs)
- I think it's a stupid argument as well.
- It's a clown argument.
This man just killed the argument.
- It's literally just like
the west versus the west.
(everyone laughs)
- We made this argument out of nothing.
- The Japanese are like, "We're
not part of this argument."
- It's that Simpsons picture
where like the people are
surrounding the two monkeys fighting.
That's the Japanese
watching anime fans argue
about if this is anime or not.
- It just felt like we were like,
this is how all religious
fighting started way back
in like the 100th century.
We just made an argument out of nothing.
(everyone laughs)
- Because yeah, because I mean, fucking,
you ask a Japanese person,
"Monsters Inc," "Shrek,"
it's all anime.
- It's just crazy to me.
- 'Cause in Japan anime
just means animation.
- I've never just had like
fucking, I got hit by a truck
when he said "Despicable Me" was an anime.
It hit me, man.
It hit me real.
Like, fuck.
I was like, "This man's
built different saying that
"like deadass."
- It would be a different
story if it was like,
"The minions are my waifu."
Like, that would have been different.
- I don't know.
I don't know why they're
obsessed with minions here!
- They're obsessed with minions in Japan.
It's fucking everywhere.
- I hate it.
- So, we visited Joey's new
apartment like last week,
and Joey's-
- Slight detour.
- Yeah, slight detour.
It will get back on topic
because he was showing us around,
and he shows us into the
last room and he's like,
"Oh, do you guys want a free gift?
"I was given a free gift
from the moving department.
"Do you guys want it?"
And we're like, "Sure, Joey, what is it?"
Deadass just brings out this
massive minions mini fridge
and expects us to take it.
And he takes this thing out,
and we're just looking at Joey being like,
"Joey, what do we want to do with this?
"What are we gonna do with this?"
And he was like,
"Maybe we can put it in
the Trash Taste studio."
I'm like, "Joey, the
Trash Taste studio isn't
"your dumping ground."
- "I have a gift" is roughly translated
to "I need to get rid of my
trash." (everyone laughs)
"Please, please take it.
"I will pay money."
- I guarantee that's
what they did to Joey.
They're all like, "Joey, I
know we're moving all the stuff
"for you, but here, have a free gift.
"Have a minions mini-fridge."
- And they're like,
"Thank God, we finally
got rid of that shit."
(everyone laughs)
- It was despicable.
- Oh my God.
Break time.
- This episode is sponsored by Vessi.
- [Connor] You're probably
wondering what is Vessi?
Well, I'm glad to answer that question.
It's a comfortable,
stylish, everyday sneaker
that you can wear even in winter.
And the best part about it
is that it's waterproof.
- 100% waterproof shoes?
- Yes, Joey.
- And one of the best parts about Vessi is
that it is super easy to clean.
Just toss on some water to it
or throw it in the washing
machine, and it'll be brand new.
- [Garnt] Vessi shoes
are made via Dyma-tex,
a dual climate knit that
keeps you cool in the summer
and warm in the winter.
It doesn't feel like it
should be waterproof at all.
- And one of the best
things about Vessi is
that it just looks like
an everyday sneaker,
so you can just wear it every single day.
And I'm very lazy
and only like to have like
one pair of shoes to wear,
so this is perfect for me.
- [Joey] Plus Vessi shoes
are sustainably made
with less material
waste, less water waste,
and no animal byproducts.
So, vegans can enjoy these as well.
- Also personally and I
know the boys can relate,
it's rainy season right now in Japan
and having a shoe that's
waterproof is very nice
because you don't have to worry
about those Goddamn
massive deceptive puddles
getting your shoes and socks wet.
- Nothing is worse than a wet sock.
- So, if that sounds interesting to you,
check them out in the description
or use coupon code TrashTaste
to get $25 off your Vessi orders.
- Look at these boys.
Back to the episode.
- Speaking of another anime
that has like really unique
voice actors in their cast,
are you guys excited for "Eden?"
- Yeah, I am actually.
That is like one that I saw
little bits and pieces of it.
I mean, I knew of it because our boy Kev-
- Our boy Kevin is doing the soundtrack.
- My boy Kevin is doing the soundtrack.
- Shout out to our boy!
- Hey!
- Now we're just simping, all right.
I'm pretty excited for it.
I mean, it's one of those
things that wasn't really
on my radar massively.
It was just like, I know
Kevin's doing the soundtrack.
I'm probably gonna watch so I can be like,
"Great job, Kevin."
- Yeah, I wasn't excited
until I saw the clips
that we were shown,
which is by the time
this podcast comes out,
the entire series would
have already been released.
But from the clips that we were shown,
I was genuinely like surprised
how excited for this I was.
I wasn't that excited before
because I didn't really
know what it was about
or how good it was gonna be.
All I know were the names
involved and what stood out
to me was of course Kevin
doing the soundtrack,
so of course I was
always going to watch it,
but then the cast list got released,
and people like David Tenant are in it,
Neil Patrick Harris.
I was like, what is going on?
- I loved them in "Smurfs."
(everyone laughs)
Sorry.
- My favorite movie.
- Yeah, it looks really good.
I mean, the clips we saw as well,
the animation looked really
fucking good for that.
Like, the way they matched the 3D
with the amazing 2D backgrounds.
Fucking amazing.
And again, the music was fucking banging.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what else to say.
I kind of want to just
wait until I watch it.
I don't wanna get too
hype for it just in case.
But it looked good.
- And it's literally out this week.
- Is it really?
I feel like it's gonna be
a seven out of 10 for me.
- Really?
- I feel, I get that vibe.
- Maybe, maybe.
It depends because it depends if it's,
like how it's going to play out,
whether it's going to be one long series
'cause it's a four episode series.
So is it going to be only four episodes
or is it gonna be like kind of
like a movie mini series kind of thing?
That's what I want to know.
- I'm hoping it fucks me up, you know?
Makes me very emotional.
But I have a feeling they're
gonna play it very safe
and it's gonna be quite like a safe story.
I just got that vibe from
the clips we watched.
So, we'll see.
I want to be pleasantly surprised.
- I got the vibes that
I was gonna feel things
by the end of it.
- Yeah, the same way I did
in the end of "Monsters Inc."
(Joey laughs)
I feel like that's-
- What are you talking about?
- When they finally, you know,
they got rid of Randall, that rascal.
- And they say goodbye to Boo.
- They say goodbye.
It's very emotional.
- "Monsters Inc." is a great movie.
- That was a terrible example.
- I cried my eyes out.
- I was just like, if it's
anything like "Monsters Inc."
I'm gonna be happy as fuck.
- I'm only thinking of
great movies right now.
I was about to say "The Incredibles."
I'm like, no, that's fantastic.
(everyone laughs)
- I feel like these are the movies
that have just been memed
so much that you forget-
- That they're actually bangers.
- That they're actually
really good movies.
- Why is this so hard to
think of subpar movies?
- Like the ending of "Mulan 2."
Straight to DVD.
- I did not even watch it.
- I haven't watched it either.
- I didn't even know
there was a "Mulan 2."
- There's a "Mulan 2"
straight to DVD movie.
But the point is that I feel like it,
again, I want it to be a
super emotional fucks me up,
but I just kinda got the
feeling it looked pretty safe.
But again, I hope it does.
I will watch it.
- I'm just wondering because
it was a Netflix adaptation,
was it cast first in English
or was it dubbed first in
English? 'Cause that's what-
- I thought it was an original story?
- I have a feeling it might've
been cast first in English.
- Yeah, because these are
some big fucking names
to put behind an anime,
and you don't normally see these names
unless it's like a Ghibli movie
where Disney is dubbing it.
So, that's what I'm most interested about.
'Cause we talked about how, you know,
in which order gets dubbed
really does I feel affects
how a dub feels.
- Well, it depends,
well, what language is
the script written in?
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- That's the big question.
'Cause you can't really write
two scripts simultaneously
that are like one-to-one.
So, it's...
- Oh, especially when it comes
to like English and Japanese
where it's like fundamentally different.
- Yeah, where the sentence
structure's opposite at times.
- I think the more I learned Japanese,
the more I appreciate what
translators have to do.
And especially when it comes
to localization the dub.
But at the same time, the
more I understand Japanese,
the more I'm just like,
man, this just doesn't give,
like I get the localization thing,
but it's just sometimes a sentence
just doesn't give me the same feeling
when I'm reading in English
versus hearing it in Japanese.
- Yeah, I think this is why
when you first start out
as an anime fan, you really
start to get into it.
You've got this thing where you're like,
"I only want pure 100% translation.
"That's all I want.
"Don't fucking,
"don't you dare change any of
the meanings of the words."
I think when you get into it more
and you start watching a lot more anime
and then it becomes a bit
tedious to watch anime
and you just kinda want
to watch it dubbed,
you kind of start to appreciate
when they just localize
it and they do it well.
- It's also the fact that
sometimes there are just some,
you know, phrases and like, you know,
meanings that just don't translate at all.
- Right, again, I mean
like one of the best dubs
of all time "Baccano,"
like there's a lot of sentences
that were just like changed to an extent
where it's not even
remotely what the guy said,
but it's the same-
- It makes sense contextually.
- It's the same kind of feeling,
but they've instead of
playing it super safe,
they were like, "No, no.
"We think we could improve
this for an English audience."
Which is a bold thing to do, you know?
And we've had a lot of failures.
We've had a lot of things
that have gone wrong.
- A lot of questionable ones.
- But I do really appreciate
when it's done right.
And I appreciate it more so
than a attempted translation
'cause I feel like the
actors have a way harder time
delivering Japanese dialogue essentially.
I mean, that's what that is.
- Because it's really hard to also perform
directly translated to Japanese dialogue
to make it sound natural in English
because there's just some
times where it's like,
that doesn't sound like
something someone would say
in English, you know?
Like, I especially felt that more when I,
'cause like when I did like
a bit of translation work
during like school and stuff like that,
and I like learned linguistics and stuff.
Like, that's where I was like,
because I also used to be
like, "How hard could it be?
"Just like direct translate it, you know,
"to get the meaning across."
But then when I actually started doing it,
I was like, "Oh no, you just can't."
Like, it's not a matter of like preference
or anything like that.
It's just like you physically can't.
There were just some Japanese
like ways of saying things
that where you just like, if
I did directly translate it,
it would just be a bunch of
words that don't mean anything.
- I think, 'cause I don't know if,
even though I spoke two
languages from birth,
I always thought as languages as like,
they're all just the same thing
just said in different ways.
But then like if that makes sense
where everything can be
one-to-one translated.
- No, no, I get what you mean.
- Every meaning can be
expressed in another language.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- I think 'cause we've been
spoiled 'cause things have been,
our whole life we've just had things
that have been translated.
- So we've never known what
the other side is like.
- It's English, it's
been translated for us.
And even again, even though
I spoke two languages,
I could never wrap my
head around this concept
until I started learning Japanese
where I was like, oh, it's just like,
it's like another planet
where it hasn't even touched anything.
I don't know how to
describe this like mental-
- It's so hard to describe
for someone who only speaks one language.
'Cause I remember the first
time I noticed this was
I was watching a Thai film with Sydney,
and I, you know, she obviously
had English subtitles on,
and as someone who speaks both
Thai and can read English,
it was really distracting;
one, because it felt like
I was hearing something
and seeing something and they
both meant the same thing
but they felt different for me.
It's this language dissonance
that I can't quite describe.
But it's something that I
feel like having now trying
to learn the language that, you know,
part of a culture and part
of like an entire country's,
you know, way of thinking
and culture is just ingrained
into a language.
It's just so much deeper than just,
I say one thing, it means another thing.
Like, I would say that depending
on what language I speak,
my personality kind of shifts as well
because it's a different
kind of way of thinking
when you're speaking another language.
It's so hard to describe
for anyone who only speaks one language,
but anyone who does
speak two languages will
probably understand that you probably have
a slightly different personality
speaking one language
compared to another.
- I apparently have a
completely different personality
when I speak Japanese compared to English.
- You're a lot softer.
- Yeah, you're a lot softer.
- What in English or Japanese?
- Japanese.
- Really?
- I think so.
- I always thought it was the opposite.
- Maybe, I don't know.
I think that's just surface level.
I don't know.
- Yeah.
- But like I also realized as well,
'cause, you know, sometimes
you're in class or whatever,
you're asking, "Oh, how do
I say this in Japanese?"
Like, no, you can't say that Japanese.
It doesn't exist in Japanese.
It's not a concept.
They've never thought of that.
- Yeah, oh God, you just fucking,
like flashback to me in school.
Everyone being like, "How do
you say fuck in Japanese?"
I'm like, how do I explain
that doesn't exist?
- And then I realized
because Welsh and English,
because although they are
entirely different languages,
everyone thinks,
"Oh, well Welsh is just
another version of English."
It's like completely different.
It's, you know-
- But you're in the UK.
You're in the same country.
- Like, German is closer
to English than Welsh is.
And it's the reason why I think
that I never had this
realization before was
because it's the culture
that you grew up in.
Because the countries
have a similar culture
now at least in the modern day.
The concepts do sort of translate
because we've made them translate.
Like, we've made the concept felt by both.
And so that-
- There isn't like the cultural gap.
- Right, right.
Because the cultural
gap is like inherently,
there's just sayings and stuff
that will never, ever have a meaning
no matter how much you
try and translate them
'cause it's just an inherent,
it's a feeling. And it's a, I don't know.
This is just a weird concept
that we're going down,
and it seems so obvious-
- None of us are linguists.
This is all just our thoughts
from learning a different language
and from speaking multiple languages.
But I think the best thought
experiment I can think of is
like anyone who speaks English,
like how would you explain
the concept of the word fuck
to someone who doesn't speak English
and somebody who didn't grow up here?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- That's like, it's,
I don't even know where I
would begin to start, you know?
Like, if you don't know, like, you know,
if you didn't grow up in the culture,
if you didn't grow up with
people saying it around you,
hearing that word
everywhere, I'm just like,
how do I explain the right
way to use the word fuck?
- I mean, I literally made a video
'cause they made an entire textbook purely
for the word fuck.
- Yeah, I've seen this.
- It's like a 70 page textbook
that goes through all the
different ways you can use fuck.
And like, I thought it was a
gag at first when I bought it.
But then when I actually
started reading, I was like,
okay, that's how you explain it.
Apparently there is a way to explain it.
It just takes 70 pages.
- And the fact that it takes 70 pages
just shows how complicated it is
even though for us it's just second nature
and it just makes sense, right?
- And like the opposite can be said
for like Japanese to English, right?
Like, how do you explain
to an English speaker
what (speaks Japanese) means?
Because like it's a purely cultural thing.
They're like, it makes
complete sense in Japanese.
But then every time,
like every time in anime
they say like (speaks Japanese)
There's always a different
way that someone's translated.
- It's a different way to translate
depending on the context of the scene
or the context of what he's saying it in.
- Like, saying, I guess so.
Like, oh, I guess so.
It's like it's not a thing in Japanese.
Can't translate it.
It's not even even in Welsh.
It's such an English thing that,
'cause none of the words mean
what they mean altogether.
It's a weird concept that we just make up.
We do that with a lot.
- I find that shit fascinating, dude.
- Bussin'.
- Yeah, bussin'.
(everyone laughs)
- The fuck is that?
- I literally just
learned that word today.
Man, I couldn't even keep
up with my own language.
How the fuck are Japanese people meant
to keep up with my language?
- But going back to anime.
- Yeah, going back to anime.
- I appreciate voice acting so much more.
I don't know if you,
I watched like two episodes of "Yasuke."
That was pretty good.
The voice acting I really enjoyed.
- I need to watch that as well.
- From two episodes, I wasn't
really sold on the story.
Again, I knew about the, if
you don't know about "Yasuke,"
the plot is essentially Nobunaga
way back in the Oda period had-
- Sengoku period.
- Sengoku period, sorry.
Sengoku period had just
met a black guy at a market
and was like, "I want
him to fight for me."
- Based on a real person as well.
- Was one of his closest
like allies, I guess.
And the story kind of expands on it.
But I saw a bunch of this on YouTube.
I thought this would be
a fucking badass anime.
Shit you not like two
weeks later got announced.
And I was like,
"Wow, I guess I should
start wishing for things."
I highly encourage you
to go read up about it.
It's super interesting and
you wouldn't expect it.
- It's also done by LeSean Thomas.
- Yeah, done by LeSean Thomas.
- I don't know who the
animation studio is.
- MAPPA.
- Oh, is it MAPPA?
- But I do think that
if you want to learn,
this is not like the best of explaining,
at least from the first
two episodes, I was like,
"This is wildly different from-"
- You said there was like magic.
- There's magic, there's mechs and stuff.
And it's like-
- I'm pretty sure that
didn't exist in feudal Japan.
- Well yeah, I mean-
- That was literally LeSean
Thomas going, "fuck it."
- I get it, you're an anime-
- Throw everything in.
- Go crazy with it.
But in some aspects I'm also like,
this is such a fucking
badass story by itself
that it doesn't need anything added.
It's so Goddamn, like
the best parts of like,
again I've only watched two out of six,
the best parts of the first two episodes
where the parts were like pre,
'cause there's a time skip,
pre-time skip where there's
like no magic or shit
where he's just fighting sword to sword.
Man to man combat, it's so Goddamn good.
And the story and it builds on all the,
obviously back then there'd
be a lot of issues with race.
- Yeah, of course.
Of course.
- They weren't too happy about
it when Nobunaga was like,
"This is my best friend."
You know, and building on
that was so interesting.
And I thought like the best
parts of the anime were that.
And again, yeah, the
story is just so cool.
Like, go read up about it.
There's tons of YouTube videos about it.
- I actually like went and
like fucking researched.
- It's so fucking cool.
- The real life Yasuke just
'cause like I had no fucking idea.
- It's a badass story.
- Oh yeah, it's fucking badass.
It's like it's so bizarre
that it could be fictional.
- Do you feel like the mech
and magic aspects added
to that story or do you
think it felt out of place?
- For me personally I
didn't really enjoy it.
I was hoping-
- You just wanted-
- The story of Yasuke,
that's what I wanted.
- You wanted like a "Samurai
Champloo" style like story.
- Kind of, I mean, but then again, like-
- Is that historically accurate?
- No, no.
(everyone laughs)
- Breakdancing samurai.
- There weren't magic and mechs.
- The music in the first two episodes
is pretty fucking good.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's really good.
The voice acting, top fucking notch.
Even the Japanese is really good.
And like, you know, even in the Japanese,
Yasuke is played by a black Japanese guy,
which is insane to see.
- [Garnt] That's awesome.
- It's normally not on the priority list.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's really
cool seeing that, you know.
Why wouldn't you want that?
Yeah, I mean, everything
else about it, I was digging.
Everything.
You know, I haven't really been motivated
to watch the rest of it.
But I think that's 'cause the
mechs thing's kinda put me off
and the magic and stuff.
Oh man.
- I mean, the short clips
I watched of it was,
like I didn't realize it was like gonna be
that fucking bloody and gory as well.
- Oh, dude, it's good.
- Like, some of the
scenes like reminded me
of like a 90s OVA, like
"Ninja Scroll" level.
- Feels like "Kill Bill" at some points.
- Yeah, it was like "Kill
Bill," "Ninja Scroll"
like levels of like, ooh!
Ooh, that's brutal!
- It's so good.
- I love it.
- Yeah, I still haven't seen it, but I-
- Check it out.
- I will, I will definitely check it out.
- You'll know if it's for you
in the first two episodes.
- Because like I really like
LeSean Thomas' work anyway,
so I was gonna watch it.
It's just hard to find time
with all the fucking anime
in the season and everything
which you two don't know about.
- Can't relate.
- I've been meaning to watch a bunch.
I've been meaning to watch "86."
- "86" is actually really good.
I probably say that's my favorite.
Oh, I can't say favorite.
It's hard.
It's definitely top three
of my favorite anime
out this season right now.
And it just feels good to
have an original mecha show
that just gives me the same feeling
as like some of the OG mecha shows
that made me really,
really like the genre.
Because it feels like it's been so long
since we've just had a
non-Gundam, non-Code Geass,
or non-big franchise mecha show
that has actually been
really, really good.
Because most of the mecha shows I remember
that's been coming out
recently have either been
like "Darling in the
Franxx" where I get invested
and it kind of does shit that falls flat,
or like I've really enjoyed-
- And then triggers like let me introduce.
(everyone laughs)
- And then you've had
things like "SSSS Gridman"
which fucking amazing show,
but it's like, it's a mecha show,
but it's also a bit tokusatsu.
So, it's not like, it's like-
- It's not like a vanilla
mecha show, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Vanilla.
- Vanilla mecha where it's
just mecha and that's it.
- But "86," you know,
gives me the same feelings
of when I first watched "Code Geass"
or the mechs that I
watched in the mid-2000s
that really made me
love the fucking genre.
It's still early days.
I don't know if it's
gonna be like 24 episodes
or 12 episodes where there's
gonna be a complete story.
I'm really hoping so.
But it's just really, really good.
- Fair enough.
- I mean, do you know
the story of it at all?
- I don't want to know anything.
All I've heard that it's good.
And I'm gonna watch it.
- Just go into it blind
is the best way I think.
- I watched "The Way of the
Husband" on Netflix as well.
- "The Way of the Househusband."
- That's it, yeah.
I mean, I enjoyed it a lot.
I thought it was very funny.
I haven't had an anime
that made me laugh out loud constantly.
- Yeah, it's hilarious.
- For like two hours.
I mean, I thought it was gonna be
like 10 episodes, 24 minutes,
but it's like five episodes
of like 12, 15 minutes.
- Yeah, I only saw three episodes.
I was like, I got the rest
of the season to binge.
I didn't know it was only five episodes.
- It's five episodes.
It kinda sucked that it literally
just like, it just ended.
It was like, there's the last skit.
It's done.
Bye bye.
And then it was like, there
was no ending or anything.
It wasn't like, "See ya
next time" or anything.
It was just like, "Okay, skit over.
"Go the fuck home, get outta here."
- 'Cause each of the chapters
in the manga are really,
really short, like maybe like
five, six pages like max.
- I thought the pacing was fantastic.
I knew obviously it caused
a lot of controversy
with the animation.
I saw a lot of people
complaining on Twitter.
I couldn't decide.
I flip-flopped.
There was some sketches where
I felt they did really good.
And there was some where I'm like,
"Holy fuck, this was so lazily done."
And it depended on the sketch.
- Well, I think it just went
down to the classification
'cause I think we've
briefly talked about this
on "Trash Taste After Dark"
where like my opinion of it was
that it's not so much an
anime in the traditional sense
where it's basically just a motion comic.
It is just a motion-
- I wish it was labeled
that and advertised as that
instead of anime adaptation.
- But I feel if you've labeled it
as "motion comic adaptation,"
then I think less people would
have been interested in it,
unfortunately.
- True, but then also
you set this expectation
that this is gonna be a
thing that might happen.
- Because I feel like it was that
and it being on Netflix as well.
Netflix really picking this up,
which gave it like people
preconceived expectations.
'Cause to me, I watched it, I
thought it was funny as fuck.
I thought the animation
worked for some of the jokes.
- Again, like, it's up there with, like,
I thought it was just as funny
as like "Sakamoto" for me,
if not funnier.
Like, it was so Goddamn funny,
and it scratched that itch
that I didn't know I was longing for.
- Yeah.
- Every single episode
I was fucking cackling,
laughing out loud alone.
- It's like that weird
like surrealist comedy.
- It's so good.
- You just don't know
what he's gonna say next,
what's gonna happen.
- Every time you feel like you
figured out how absurd he is,
he just does something else.
And you're like, this is fucking funny.
If you haven't watched
it, please go watch it.
It's just about like a Yakuza
member who gets married
and straightens out
and has become a housewife, househusband.
And yeah, it's just really funny.
But it would have been at like,
it would have been a
nine or a 10 for me if,
again, like, I don't know.
I don't really like the add
of the motion comic style.
- Do you think it would have been funnier
with say just mediocre adaptation?
- Honestly, yeah.
- Mediocre animation.
- Genuinely, yeah.
'Cause there was so
little animation on anyway
and there's just times I'm like,
I wish they just did a little bit on this
just to help sell the joke.
- I feel like the lack of
animation helps sell some jokes
if anything.
- I agree, I agree.
- Just some of them.
Just because some of it
just looks ridiculous.
And that to me just made it more funny.
- But imagine this anime
in like "Nichijou" style.
- Yeah, but like name another comedy anime
that's on "Nichijou" level.
- There isn't, but I'm just saying like,
if you had the choice.
- No, if I had the choice between that,
I'd always go for fucking
"Nichijou" animation
even like "KonoSuba" animation.
'Cause "KonoSuba," I think a
lot of people underestimate
how good the character
animation in "KonoSuba" is.
That really sold so much of
the voice acting performance
where a lot of other comedy
anime I feel have fallen flat
because you have amazing
voice acting performance,
you have amazing source material,
and the animation is just like-
- Okay.
- The most okay animation.
It really does nothing to
enhance the source material.
- Maybe I'm being too
hard on it. I don't know.
I think I was just shocked
at how little there was.
- Yeah.
Whereas with "Way of the Househusband,"
it had amazing voice acting obviously,
had amazing source material,
and I feel like because they didn't try,
it kind of like suited that
comedy style perfectly.
And I feel like to me,
if you couldn't have amazing animation,
I would have preferred to
have it have like just,
not even like bad animation,
just like a very unique
style of limited animation
that really helps sell some of the weirder
and more ridiculous parts of the manga
'cause it is a ridiculous manga,
and I feel like the animation
style helped accentuate
some of the ridiculous moments to me.
- Yeah, there's some
moments where I was like,
"Yeah, okay, this joke
works with this animation."
There's others where I'm like,
"This really needed more to
help sell some of this joke."
I don't know, personally.
- I feel like maybe a mix could have
like really, really propelled it.
- Have you seen clips of the,
there's a Japanese live action adaptation.
Have you seen this?
- [Garnt] I have not.
- I've seen it, yeah.
- It's so bad!
It's so funny!
It's like (laughs)
- It's tragic.
- Wait, what's that?
Describe it to me.
- It's just like, okay, the main guy,
it looks like a cosplay.
It doesn't look-
- It is a cosplay!
- Like, it looks like a cosplay,
not like an actual actor.
Like, the guy isn't like built enough.
- It is like "Full Metal
Alchemist" live action level.
- Oh my God!
- And then his friend in the anime
who was really young and supposed to be
like the young gang member
looks really fucking old
and like-
- I didn't watch it like fully.
I only watched like
clips of it on YouTube,
and I was just like, "Oh no."
- It's bad.
I watched the same skit,
both of them and compared.
The humor wasn't nearly as
good in the live action.
Like, I don't know why.
I feel like they didn't like,
'cause with animation you
can really sell the absurdity
and the live action one-
- That's the point, right?
- Yeah, but it didn't work very well.
- Yeah, I feel like-
- Also Japanese acting in TV shows,
I don't know how they are so bad,
but I've never seen
Japanese acting in a TV show
and been like, "That's fantastic."
- Unless it's like Ken Watanabe.
- Literally, it's like he's the only one.
I feel bad saying that
'cause I feel like that's
such a broad statement,
but I've watched so much Japanese TV
and all the drama acting is appalling.
- Yeah, it's not good.
- It's so bad.
- Especially in like the live action.
Like, especially when a
live action anime adaptation
of a Japanese TV show or a Japanese anime,
it's always, it's so weird
seeing live action actors try
to act like anime characters
or doing like the anime style acting.
- 'Cause you watch like Korean dramas
and Korean adaptations and
stuff, and it's so much better.
I watched like "Sweet Home,"
the web tune adaptation into Netflix,
and the actors were fucking amazing in it.
- There's a live action adaptation?
- Live action.
- Oh shit, I gotta watch that.
- And the acting was really fucking good.
Like, every single time
I've watched a Korean movie
or Korean drama, I'm always so impressed
at how fucking good, not to
say that the actors are bad.
But I just thought for
some reason, I'm like,
oh, I've seen Japanese acting.
It's gonna be over the
top dramatic all the time.
- I feel like, especially in recent years,
Korean movies and Korean dramas
and shows have just like,
they are like,
they are way ahead of like
Japanese J dramas and J movies.
- So many movies where I'm like
fucking compared to English,
it like shits on them.
Like, some of the,
like "Old Boy," like I love that movie.
- Fucking.
And that's actually based
on a manga, did you know?
- I didn't know that.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, "Old Boy" was originally a manga.
It got adapted into a Korean movie.
- Oh, that's cool.
- That movie is like one
of my favorite movies
of all time.
- It's fucking amazing.
- The acting is so Goddamn
good in that movie.
- The cinematography is fantastic.
- That's one of the greatest
foreign films of all time,
and it's, you know, it's up
there with like "Parasite"
as like, to me, as one of the
best Korean movies I've seen.
There are so many good
Korean movies, right?
And I feel like people
are now just figuring out
that man, Koreans make good movies.
- Oh yeah, they're very good.
- "Train to Busan" as well.
- Oh, that's a fantastic movie.
- I remember first time
watching "Train to Busan"
I was like, "I've seen zombie movies.
"I know how this works."
And for some reason it didn't do like,
on like, you know, on paper,
it doesn't do that much different
to every other zombie movie.
But it's just so fucking good.
I can't pinpoint why it was so good,
but it's just...
- I don't know what it is,
like when I watch Japanese TV,
I feel like it's like a pantomime.
You know what I mean?
It does feel like that level
of acting where it's like,
"Is there somebody behind me?
"I better not look."
And then, "Whoa!"
- I feel like with Japanese acting,
it's very reminiscent
to anime, anime acting,
which anime acting works for anime,
but it doesn't work for
live action acting at all.
- Yeah, well I was asking
some friends, I'm like, oh,
'cause I was watching with them,
I'm like, "Are they famous?
"Are they famous?"
They're like, "Oh yeah,
they're a famous voice actor."
And it's like, when you're
a famous voice actor,
you can get roles in TV shows.
And it's kind of strange
'cause it's normally the other way around
with, you know, western stuff.
It's just odd to think.
'Cause I feel like as someone
who does voice acting,
it does not translate to the IRL acting.
Like-
- It's a completely different skillset.
- Yeah, I mean, you understand
the fundamentals of acting,
but you know, can you hit the mark?
You know, you're not
being told how to walk.
You're not being told
how to act physically.
That's what you do have to learn.
That is separate.
- There's a lot you don't think about.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's interesting.
I just wonder why?
I sit there and I'm just confused.
I'm like, why is Japanese acting
like generally not as good?
Not saying that there's
zero Japanese good actors,
just saying in general
the TV production is
pretty lackluster.
- I think maybe it's because
like they don't really think of
like outside of Japan movie industry
as much of a competition.
Like, they might think it's like,
because you know, with like,
you know, Hollywood films,
like English speaking films,
like, you're not only
competing with Hollywood,
but you're competing
with literally every other
English speaking country,
every other English speaking production.
Whereas I feel the Japanese
film industry is kind of
in its own bubble.
They're kind of just like-
- No driving force.
- There's no like driving
force or like threat
to make them be like, "We
gotta step up our game."
Or like, or maybe the fact that like,
they're probably like just unaware.
They probably just think
like, "Well, you know,
"English speaking productions
and like other productions
"that aren't Japanese do this in this way,
"but for us, this works
with our type of audience."
So, there's no like they
probably don't even think
this is bad acting.
- Yeah, I'm sure people are
gonna comment and be like,
"There are so many good Japanese films."
- Yeah, there are.
- There are a lot of good Japanese films.
But it's a lot rarer to find a
really, really good Japanese-
- They come few and far in between.
Especially in like J dramas, I feel.
- J dramas is even harder.
- Holy fuck, that's what I mean.
That's where you really see the pinnacle.
- I feel like the right
way to describe J dramas
from like the majority I've watched is
just they are very campy.
- Yeah, that's what I mean.
It's pantomime.
Everything is fucking over the top.
- It's so campy.
And, you know, there's
an audience for that.
And there's like a, you know,
there's, you know, I
do enjoy some J dramas,
but it's less of, "I
think this is a good show"
and more just like, "I can
just get behind this show.
"You know, I like whatever
source material it's adapting."
- And also I don't, frankly,
I don't give a fuck about cinematography.
I don't really care too much.
I'm not very picky, you know?
- Well, that's good because J
drama has zero cinematography.
- J dramas they shoot it
like a fucking daytime TV commercial.
Why does it look like that?
Like, I never thought I
would give a shit about that
until I watched J drama.
- That's the point.
You don't give a about cinematography
until you see something
that has no cinematography.
- Like, what are you gonna
fucking advertise to me a plunger
that has four and one any second now.
Waiting for it.
'Cause of how it's shot.
It's ridiculous. I don't
know why it looks like that.
It's so weird.
- Yeah, I feel like I've
seen some YouTube videos
with better cinematography than
some of the stuff out there.
in J dramas right now.
- Broaden in Japan channels.
(everyone laughs)
- 100%.
That'll make up for the
lack of his signature.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, I hate shitting on it.
'Cause I don't really understand why.
I don't really know if they care.
I don't really know if
there's a want to improve.
- I just don't think
the audience is there.
- No, the audience doesn't give a shit.
- Well, it's normal,
I mean, the majority of the
population here is older.
So generally-
- To be fair, I have
seen a bunch of J dramas
where the cinematography is absolute ass,
but I've still enjoyed it
because the story was just
genuinely really, really good.
And it wasn't until like,
it was like an afterthought of like,
"Oh yeah, that was a good J drama."
But the cinematography was shit.
- I saw this one and it was like,
I think it was like a James Bond show.
And it was like, this Japanese guy looked
like Japanese George Clooney.
It was really cool.
- Really?
- I was like, "Holy shit, this guy's hot."
- I think I know who you're
talking about actually.
Yeah, he looks kind of western.
- He looks western,
but I looked it up and he's 100% Japanese.
But he looks like George
Clooney if he was Japanese.
- I think I know who you're talking about.
I don't know his name.
- And he was just like a
no nonsense attitude guy.
He's like, "I'm coming
to get the information."
And just like beat this guy up.
With terrible lighting and cinematography.
But it was like, really?
I don't know why I'm talking about this.
I was just fascinated by him.
I was like that man's so Goddamn hot.
Good for him. I wish I was that hot.
- Because I've always 'cause
I've had the movie experience
of, "Wow, this movie has fucking
fantastic cinematography.
"Unfortunately the rest
of the movie is shit."
(everyone laughs)
What was that movie?
It was the something
still water or something
where it's like...
No, no.
It was originally supposed
to be the Bioshock movie,
but then they like changed
it halfway through.
- What?
- I do not know.
- I have no idea.
Do you want to-
- Yeah, let me look it up.
I know exactly what it is.
But like the movie had like the most
like amazing fucking cinematography.
It looked fucking incredible.
Like, it was stylized perfectly,
really creepy cinematography.
- Look it up.
- Yeah.
I remember.
"A Cure For Wellness."
- I haven't seen that movie.
- Oh, that's a horror movie.
- Yeah, the horror movie.
"A Cure For Wellness."
That was apparently,
that was originally supposed
to be the Bioshock movie.
And you can tell-
- Looks nothing like Bioshock.
- No, obviously they like
completely changed the story.
- That threw me off
when you said it's meant
to be the Bioshock movie.
- Supposedly it was supposed
to be the Bioshock movie,
but then something happened legality wise,
and they were like,
"All right, time to rewrite
the story completely."
But like when you just
look at the cinematography
and like the sets and
stuff like that, I'm like,
"Okay, I can kind of see
what they were going for."
Like, this looks cool.
It's very stylized.
Cinematography is great.
Unfortunately, the story was like, what?
Like, what the fuck is happening?
Nothing makes sense.
Characters were all shit.
So, like that's when I got
to the point, I was like,
would I have preferred this movie
if it had shit cinematography
but a good story
versus great cinematography
but a shit story?
- And this is like the
animation versus story debate
that anime fans go through.
- Like, which do you prefer?
If you had to choose.
- Story, story.
But it has to be well acted.
You can't sell me on a bad
story with not with actors
who don't sell the moment.
- "The Room" is pretty good.
"The Room" is pretty good.
- I mean, that's a masterpiece.
- A unique exception.
- But that's called brilliant acting.
I don't know what you're
talking about. (everyone laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What a top grade actor.
- Yeah, I mean, no.
'Cause like, I feel like,
I guess watching a lot
of J dramas reminds me of
like the old Thai soap operas
I would see my mom watching
and I'm just like, what
the fuck is this, Mom?
Like, what the hell are you watching?
- Like the Indian shows as well.
- I feel like that's
just a genre of itself
where you got like the campiest,
most melodrama shit going on.
Don't know what's going on.
You see out of context clips.
I think even some Korean
dramas do this as well.
It's just not as well known.
Like, I remember seeing one clip
where it was a Korean drama and-
- The one where he's
falling down the stairs?
- No, no, that's the Bollywood one.
- I think that's the Bollywood one.
The one I was thinking
of where this woman,
this guy says something and
this woman takes this entire
like fucking cabbage of kimchi
and just slaps this guy.
(everyone laughs)
I just like, I just want to
know the context of this.
'Cause out of context
it just makes no sense.
- We just have to remind our audience
that this is a Korean production.
Bring out the kimchi.
(everyone laughs)
- Didn't like, didn't Pewdiepie react
to like a Bollywood clip
and then there was like
drama or something about it?
Like, they like-
- Was it?
- I swear there was drama.
I don't know if I'm
remembering this incorrectly,
but like there was like
a clip that he reacted to
and it was 'cause there
was like a reaction image
where she was like (gasps)
and then it was like 20
shots of like zooming in.
- Yeah, it's the woman falling off
like the balustrade, right?
- Is that what it is?
- Oh, I've seen that one!
- And the guy's like slow
motion trying to catch him.
But it's like going back and forth.
And it's like this woman's been
in the air for five minutes.
(everyone laughs)
It's a second floor.
- This woman's like
literally fucking airbending
right in front of my eyes.
Everyone's just like
watching it in slow motion.
It's fucking hilarious.
I love that.
- It's so funny.
- I swear he got into some spat
or something because of it.
You keep talking.
- No, I would love to
react to Indian soap operas
out of context.
I feel like there's
every other soap opera,
and then there's just Indian soap opera.
- Oh yeah.
They take campiness to the next
level, and it's so amazing.
- Have you ever seen like
many Bollywood movies?
- There was a period in my life
where I tried to get
into Bollywood movies.
But the problem is is that
there are so many fucking films
in the Bollywood like scene.
- Yeah, I didn't realize
how many movies they made.
- It's like, they make
like fucking five, 10 times
as much as like Hollywood.
It's insane.
So, I'm just like, I
legitimately was like,
where the fuck do I even begin?
Because like I don't know anybody else
who like has stepped into that territory.
And so like my only other
option was to like go
on the internet and be like,
"best Bollywood movies."
- Top 10 Bollywood films of all time.
Thank you, Watch Mojo.
Here's my watch list right now.
- But then every fucking like
top 10, top 50 list I saw was
just like all completely,
there wasn't a single like
entry where it was like,
"Oh, I saw that on this page."
It's all fucking different.
So I'm like, what do I just have to like-
- Number one, "Slumdog Millionaire."
(everyone laughs)
- Do I literally just have to like...
That's a great movie though.
- It's not Bollywood.
But I remember when that came out,
people were like yeah, I like Bollywood.
- "Slumdog Millionaire."
- It's good, it's good.
- Yeah, so I'm like, do I just
have to like bite the bullet
and just like pick a random one
and just like hope that it's a good movie?
I don't know.
Please let us know in the comments.
What's a good Bollywood film?
- The only one I can
remember that I watched
that I think is really good is
a film called "Three Idiots."
And the only reason I watched it was
'cause it was on the
IMDb top 100 at the time.
I was like, "What is this?"
And it's a concept I feel like
that was made for Indians.
Because it's a film, get
this, about engineers.
(everyone laughs)
I think it was like actual,
I can't remember if they
were all mechanical engineers
or electrical engineers.
- It doesn't matter.
They were engineers.
- It was just so weird
seeing this engineering movie
and then out of nowhere they
just break out into song
and dance.
(everyone laughs)
- There's nothing I hate
more than fucking musicals.
I cannot stand-
- You don't like musicals?
- I hate musicals.
- I actually agree with Connor.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- It's like, if I want a musical,
I'll fucking pause the
movie and go on Spotify
and play Daft Punk four minutes.
Don't get in the way, man.
I hate musicals so Goddamn much.
I cannot, I would rather do anything else.
- I'm like, I'm very hit
or miss with musicals.
Like, a lot of musicals I'm
just like fucking whatever.
But then if you like,
like I could watch like
"Rocky Horror" like 30 times.
- I feel like to me
musical works well on like
when it's a stage, you know, when it's-
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- When you're watching it live,
it's a really, really amazing experience.
Like, I remember watching
"Les Miserables."
I'm sure I fucking butchered that.
- Less Miserables.
- Les Miserables.
I remember watching that
in England at the West End.
Fucking amazing experience.
And then I remember watching the movie,
and I'm just like,
"This is really boring."
I don't know.
- I watched it for the first
time like pretty recently
just 'cause Aki was like,
"Oh, you have to watch it."
- No, you don't.
- "It's great."
I'm just like, okay, well, you know,
I always give musicals
a go, so it's whatever.
This might be the rare time where,
like "Rocky Horror" where it's like,
oh I might fucking fall in love with it.
I'm just like, Goddamn,
they haven't stopped singing
for like two hours.
- It just feels like a
fucking quick time event.
Like, when you're in a musical.
It's like, "I guess I'll press X.
"Fuck, I'll press X."
It just feels like it doesn't fucking end.
It's like unskippable cutscenes and shit.
It's like, get this shit outta here.
- Well, what I like about like
"Rocky Horror" for instance,
is that like; one, it's fucking weird,
two, it's fucking Tim
Curry in like leggings
which is just like
amazing just conceptually.
But like what I like about "Rocky Horror"
compared to like say like
"Les Miserables" is like,
"Les Miserables" is just like 90% singing
and then 10% dialogue.
Whereas "Rocky Horror" is like 50/50.
So, it's like you get the
enjoyment of like an actual movie
like type of story
and every now and then
it goes into like song.
- But when I'm watching
a musical, I'm just like,
just get to the story.
Why am I here?
I don't care about the song and dance.
Just get to the story.
Give me the story.
- The only time I actually
think I liked a musical was,
what is it?
"Little Shop of Horrors" right?
That has like a lot of music in it.
The one with the big plant.
- Oh yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
- That's a musical, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think I liked that
'cause it made the
thing fucking terrifying
when it started singing.
It sold me on the horror
'cause when this giant plant
puppet started singing,
as like a 15-year-old kid
I was like, "Holy shit!"
- It's like the kind of
like jazzy style, like yeah!
- It was terrifying.
(Joey laughs)
- Did you ever watch
"Bugsy Malone" as a kid?
- What?
- "Bugsy Malone."
- I know the name.
I don't know anything about it though.
- Yeah, it's, I can't remember
'cause I only have vivid
memories of watching as a kid.
All I know it was like, it's
like set in like, you know,
in the prohibition era.
And it's about a bunch of
people running speakeasies.
But for some reason,
everyone of the gangsters
who are, you know, who are in this movie,
everyone's played by kids.
And when they have Tommy guns,
instead of firing bullets,
they fire like a cream pie.
So, whenever someone gets hit
by a cream pie in the face,
they're dead.
Like, thinking back as a
kid, it's the most like,
this is the weirdest fever
dream I'm describing right now.
But it exists!
- This sounds like a David
Lynch film, you know?
It's like that weird.
- It sounds like on the same level
as what are those fucking dogs called?
The movies where they
just like dub over dogs?
- What?
- It was literally like
Air Buddy or some shit.
It's like a whole fucking series.
- Oh!
Like "Snow Dogs."
Like, that level.
- It sounds like that
where they just fucking
dub over dogs doing shit.
Oh my God.
- I've been trying to find
someone else in my life
who also has this vivid memory
of watching "Bugsy Malone"
as a kid 'cause I just want
to reconfirm that it's real.
That this was real!
It really happened!
I just need to know, okay?
So far I've, you know, maybe
it was just my school thing.
Maybe it was my generation thing.
I don't know.
But I have not met a
single other person IRL
who remembers watching "Bugsy Malone."
So, please comment section,
if there's someone in the
comments section who knows
who has watched "Bugsy
Malone" before, please,
please tell me 'cause I need
to know I'm not fucking crazy.
I need to know this wasn't a fever dream.
I need to know if this really happened.
- Everyone in the comments,
just be like, "I have no idea."
- It was a musical so-
- It's a musical as well?
No.
- That's why I remember it.
It was a musical.
- Real question though, did you
guys watch the "Cats" movie?
- No, I didn't.
- I saw half.
- Why did you watch it?
- 'Cause I was just like, 'cause I,
who doesn't look at
that trailer and think,
"This looks like shit.
"I'm gonna watch it."
- Like, you know when
you just see ads so often
for something that you've decided
you're gonna dislike this
thing before you see anything.
That was me with "Cats"
'cause it was just everywhere
and it was so obnoxious.
And they do that thing with like,
"This has never been done before.
"This has literally
never been done before."
Like, they just say that about anything.
Like, "We've never had this.
"We've never experienced this.
"We all felt amazing on the set."
I don't give a fuck.
- The thing is with "Cats"
is that I've seen it
on stage before.
And like, I actually thought,
not my favorite musical,
but I was like, okay,
out of all the musicals
I've seen on stage,
it's pretty all right.
It's pretty decent.
Like, it's a good story.
The songs are pretty all right.
But then when you watch that trailer,
and you see the horrific
things in that trailer,
you're just like, "Well, you
have piqued my interest now."
Fucking green screen like huge artists,
like on these like fucking cat like,
basically these huge actors being furries.
- I swear there was like really
funny, like cast interviews.
- Really?
- Where like the cast were
like, "I don't fucking know."
(Joey laughs)
"What do you want me to say?"
I love it when actors like give interviews
and they just fucking
shit on what they're in.
There's something really
cathartic about it.
And like they're like, "Yeah, it sucks."
- Like, the fucking Robert Patterson one.
- Yeah, the Robert Patterson one.
"I can't fucking stand Twilight."
Like, Robert Patterson please.
Have we spoke about this
before on the podcast?
- Yeah, we were talking
about it before in private.
- Robert Patterson hated
being in "Twilight"
and his interviews about
it are so fucking funny.
Like Daniel Craig in James Bond.
- Did we talk about this?
- I don't remember.
- Literally can't remember
if we talked about this
on the podcast.
- Apologies if we said it already.
- We must've spoke
about it on set I think.
Daniel Craig hates being
in 007, in "James Bond."
The interviews that he
gave were so fucking funny.
He did like a quote where he said like,
"I'd rather cut myself
than do another Bond film."
And then he did another Bond film.
(everyone laughs)
It's so funny.
It's just like-
- It's so tragic.
- It's like imagine
getting hired back again
by the people you're just shitting on.
"I would rather die than
work for you again."
- And they're like,
"Let's get him back on."
- "Let's get this guy back."
Like, how out of options must they be
to have to like bring
Daniel Craig back in.
They must have thrown so much money.
- Because I'm pretty sure
he must've signed a contract
before otherwise it's like-
- Really?
- Yeah, 'cause you know,
if you break contract,
I'm pretty sure that you're
just like blacklisted
from Hollywood, right?
'Cause that's why like no
one really breaks contracts.
- Either that or they must
have given Daniel Craig
a fat fucking paycheck.
- I'm sure they gave him a lot of money.
- I'm pretty sure they
gave him a lot of money.
- Didn't they have to do
something 'cause he like.
in the, which movie was it?
What was the most recent film?
- The one after "Skyfall" right?
- Yeah, the one after "Skyfall."
- There was one after "Skyfall?"
- Yeah.
- God, I'm so behind on my Bond movies.
- Well, there was one where in the casino,
it was a casino scene,
where he like-
- I was about to say.
(everyone laughs)
- "Spectre."
- Type in Daniel Craig gloves.
There was a thing where
they had to like CGI
I think gloves on or off of him
because he just left them on
because he liked them or something.
- What?
- Yeah.
So yeah, he bought gloves
before like filming
and he really wanted to wear them,
and so they had to like
CGI the gloves off of him.
Because he wanted to wear them.
Is that right?
Can you Google it?
It was something like that.
He was so fucking done with this shit
that he impulse bought
gloves and was like,
I'm wearing them on the
film. I don't give a fuck.
And they had to CGI them off of him!
- CGI artists like cracking
their necks being like,
all right.
- I couldn't do that just
out of feeling horrible
to the people who have
to work on that CGI.
But you've got to respect the level of
"I don't give a fuck."
- Just a new level of just,
yeah, don't give a fuck.
- That's the most passive
aggressive way of being like,
"Don't call me back, please."
- You're literally on like a
half a billion dollar movie
and you just don't give a fuck
about wearing your like $2,200 gloves.
You're like, "Ah, who cares?"
(everyone laughs)
- It's also just like the
choice of gloves as well
of all things you could have put on is
just like the biggest fuck you.
- Just, I don't know what about it-
- Hilarious.
- It's just so cathartic
to just hear this.
I don't know why.
It's so funny just hearing
individuals be like,
"Fuck you, big movie corporation.
"I'm going to do what I want."
And then they just roll with it.
They're like, "I guess
we'll fix it in post?"
- "I guess we can't get him
to take his gloves off?"
- "Skyfall" yeah.
Okay, okay.
(everyone laughs)
- And he's in the new one as well.
And I think the new one is
supposedly his last one.
But it got delayed because of COVID.
- I'm pretty sure that's what they said
about "Skyfall" as well.
- They said that about
like the last three films.
But they don't know
who's gonna replace him.
- That's so weird.
'Cause I remember a time like, you know,
in like the late 90s,
early 2000s where like,
I feel every "James Bond" movie,
there was a different James Bond.
- No, they did like two or
three I think each at least.
- I feel like they were
like replacing them
like quicker than Daniel Craig, right?
- No, I mean-
- Pierce Brosnan did a lot.
- Pierce Brosnan did five maybe?
- But he probably also enjoyed
it unlike Daniel Craig.
- I think he got his
paycheck and he yeeted out.
I think he got what he got.
- What else has Daniel Craig done
apart from "James Bond" recently?
- He's done a few pretty good films.
I can't remember any
off the top of my head.
He did, like, I really liked
him in like "Layer Cake."
- Oh!
"Layer Cake!"
- That was a really British film.
- I've completely forgot about that.
- I like him in everything
else but "James Bond."
I think he's really good in
everything but "James Bond."
- Yeah, but I feel like in "Layer Cake,"
he also just played Daniel Craig, right?
- But he played it better.
- He just kind of played James
Bond in a different skin.
You know, it was...
Kind of very felt James Bond.
- It was Daniel Craig playing James Bond
playing Daniel Craig.
(everyone laughs)
- I feel like James Bond is
just an outdated archetype.
- I feel like it is as well.
- You watch it nowadays and you're like,
they've tried their best to kind of-
- Modernize it.
- But it still feels like
when they're trying to put
like the Playboy scenes in,
you're like, this is
kind of cringe nowadays.
I don't know why, but
just seeing a guy just go,
"Yes, I'm going to fuck these two women."
It's like, all right, okay, sure.
- We get it, man.
You get pussy.
- What did you match them on Tinder?
- Don't have to brag about it.
- It just felt very like nowadays,
it just feels like, oh,
this feels kind of lame.
- Yeah, I mean, it's a
very dated archetype.
Like, I can't imagine anyone,
like imagine if I'm just like,
"My name is Maneetapho.
"Garnt, Maneetapho."
- That's you with the outfit.
(everyone laughs)
The glasses, right?
- You're wearing the turtleneck.
(everyone laughs)
Well, that's why I really
enjoyed "Kingsman," right?
- "The names Job.
"Steve Handjobs."
- Steve Handjobs.
- "Kingsman" was good
until the second movie.
- Yeah, yeah. That's why I
really liked the first movie
because it completely just
like almost made fun of that.
- That was really good.
I really liked it.
And then it became the archetype.
- And then it became the
archetype, yeah, exactly.
How the fuck did we get
on about James Bond films?
- I don't fucking, we were
talking about musicals.
Oh, have you ever,
I was thinking about-
- We're really good at tangents today.
- I was thinking about
musicals I actually like.
The only ones I probably
actually like were
the "South Park Movie."
- Oh, that is a musical, isn't it?
- And you guys ever see
"The Book of Mormon" live?
- That's literally been the one,
the musical that I've
always wanted to watch.
- It's a fucking amazing musical.
And the reason I like those
musicals is the music is funny
and it plays off the joke.
And it doesn't like, I
don't care about the story.
- Me no think, me laugh.
- I don't care about
the story of South Park,
I'm there for the jokes.
And that helps add onto the jokes.
And that's why it's the only
musical I can get behind.
But yeah, I'm not really
that much of a Broadway
or West End guy, so I've only seen-
- Really, Garnt?
I thought you were.
- You seem like a Broadway
kind of gentleman.
- Stop you from singing, Garnt.
- Do I seem like a theater kid to you?
(Joey laughs)
- Have you ever been tempted
to go watch like the anime like musicals?
Have you seen any of them?
- Tempted, no.
- They restarted the
"Death Note" one, right?
- Yeah.
- How does that work?
- I've been so tempted to
go and watch it just to say
I went to go see a "Death Note" musical.
Or like the "Prince of Tennis" musical.
I really wanna go.
(everyone laughs)
- That idea wasn't in my head,
but now it is in my head.
- I've been trying to find
people to come with me
to go watch like any of the anime musicals
just because there's
something like defeatist
about being like,
"Yeah, so I went to go
watch the Death Note musical
"by myself the other day."
Like, as you do on a Sunday.
(everyone laughs)
- Dude, I'd fucking do it.
- Yeah, please.
- Fuck that.
I'll go by myself to watch
the "Death Note" musical.
- They had the "My Hero Academia" musical,
didn't they as well?
- Yeah, they did!
They did!
- That idea wasn't in my head,
but now I'm just genuinely curious.
How does that work?
- How do you adapt "Death
Note" to a musical?
♪ I like eating apples ♪
♪ Die, die, die ♪
(everyone laughs)
- I feel like you'd have to be,
I want it to be in the style
of like Willy Wonka-esque
like original, you know,
like the Oompa Loompa.
Just have Ryuk be an Oompa Loompa.
Have that kind of sing a song.
(everyone laughs)
- I would like that.
- Shinigami's just like.
- I'd like to think that the costume
for Ryuk is extremely poor as well.
It's just the shittest costume.
- Just a guy in like a gimp costume.
- He's just been like
tarred and feathered.
And he's just kind of like
overweight and he's like, "No."
Smoker's voice as well.
(everyone laughs)
(Connor speaks Japanese)
- Give me an apple and a cigarette.
- It's just fucking William
Defoe without any makeup on.
It's just William Defoe.
- Just comes out like, "It is me, Ryuk."
(everyone laughs)
- I'd buy it, I'd buy it.
He's very good actor.
He could do it.
- He's great.
- If anyone could just stand
there and make me accept it,
it's probably William Defoe.
- Yeah, of course.
- I'm just remembering the "Death Note"
live action movie now.
- He was the best part of the movie.
- He said four lines and
that was it, unfortunately.
- But he was good.
He was good in those four lines.
How'd we get onto this?
How did we tangent?
- I don't know, I don't know.
We're good at that.
- So gentlemen, moving on though,
this is now our last few
moments in the studio.
- Yeah.
- This is the last episode of season one.
- I guess it is.
- Is that what we're gonna call it?
- I don't know if we're doing
like season one via studios
or via the year.
- I mean, either way,
this is the end, right?
'Cause we're like right on,
as we're recording, this is
like one year anniversary
I'm pretty sure.
- I'm pretty sure.
I don't know.
- I think so.
Something like that.
- 53, right?
- Close enough.
- 52 weeks in a year.
- And the one over here.
(everyone laughs)
Yeah, wow.
I mean, it felt a lot longer
than a year to be honest.
- I don't remember the studio
being this full, you know?
I don't remember what
it looked like before.
- It's scary going back
to like episode one.
- Yeah.
- And being like, it doesn't
look like the same room.
- I'll tell you what,
after you mentioned it on
the Trash Taste Awards,
I remember looking at the
first episode again as well,
and I forgot that we
originally had our camera
all the way back there.
- Right in the back.
- So, it kind of looked
like you're peeking through
like, you know, like you're
peeking through being like,
"Oh, what are they getting on to?"
And now it just feels like way too close.
Hello.
This is the new camera angle
that we changed to, you know.
- What, like 30 episodes ago.
- Yeah, it just feels weird.
I forgot that we changed camera angles
and the different
feeling that it gave off.
And yeah, like I'm impressed
how many guests we got this year as well.
- Given the limited circumstances of-
- All nine of them.
(everyone laughs)
- Except for Chris.
Fuck Chris.
But yeah, I'm sure Chris will be on again.
- Yeah, of course.
- I'm sure Chris is gonna
come knocking on the door.
- Is he gonna be the first
guest on in season two as well?
- He said he wants to be.
(everyone laughs)
- Just asserting dominance
to every other guest.
- I don't see why not.
- Deadass what else is there
to talk about with Chris?
- What'd you mean?
Just have Chris on.
He's insanity in shoes.
Chris just makes funny
moments by being on.
We bully Chris.
Chris bullies us.
You know, it's a good deal.
- I'm looking forward
to what drip he's gonna
be wearing next off
after winning laziest drip in season one.
(everyone laughs)
- You know, like after
that episode goes off,
he's gonna be like, "Oh,
I gotta come with a suit."
- I told Chris, I was like,
"You won an award by the way."
He's like-
- Won two awards.
- No, no, no.
I was like, "You won an award."
He's like, "Oh really?"
I said, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
"Just one?"
(everyone laughs)
I was like, "Fuck off, Chris!"
- Lucky for you, Chris.
- I didn't tell him about the second one.
So, he'll be surprised.
- Brilliant, brilliant.
- He won't find out until-
- Yeah, he won't find
that out until that's up.
(everyone laughs)
Yeah, but I guess by the
time you see us next week,
we'll be in a hopefully brand new set up.
- Well, yeah, it'll be
like a month for us.
It'll be one week for you guys.
- A week for you guys.
- We want to remodel and
change the setup a little bit.
Get the angles different.
- We're not gonna have like
a completely different setup
right off the bat I think.
It's gonna be similar to season one
where we kind of grow our
set as the season goes on.
You know, I feel, I like that.
- We haven't decided everything yet.
- We have no idea what the
new set is gonna look like.
- I want to get all new figures.
That's what I want.
- That involves having
another Akihabara special,
which is gonna be pretty
hard right now, considering
everything is locked down.
- Yeah, true.
But in future.
- So maybe you'll have to
wait a little bit longer
compared to season one to
get a new Akihabara special.
But we do want to do one in the future.
Apart from that, I don't
know what other plans.
I'm just excited to show
you guys like the new set
that we have and having a
proper "Trash Taste" office,
not just an apartment that
we just remodeled into a set.
- I mean, you guys will see
it in the "After Dark" vlog.
I mean, like speaking of,
there'll be way more "After
Dark" content as well.
- We're gonna have two sets now.
So, the "After Dark" specials aren't
just going to be "Trash Taste" 1.5.
- Yeah, that's the main arguments,
one of the big reasons why we wanna move,
just to allow us to make more-
- More content.
- More space, more content.
'Cause right now it's, you know, I mean,
you can make content in this room.
I'm sure we could,
but it's one of those things where-
- But what cost?
- When you're in a room
that you just despise
'cause it's too cramped,
you don't want to make like stuff.
You don't feel creative.
You don't feel like you
want to do anything.
Like, you guys will see when we vlog it,
but like behind the set
is an absolute mess.
And actually, the set is a mess.
- The entire room, the
entire place is a mess.
- The beauty of camera angles
is everything looks bigger,
but this is, it is not as
neat as you think it is.
In fact like I get actually
like physically embarrassed,
whenever a guest comes over.
- It's pretty embarrassing.
- Because the one thing,
the one mutual thing
that every guest says is,
"Wow, this place is a lot
smaller than it looks."
(everyone laughs)
Like, yeah, we know, we know.
- It's like, you know,
when your mom comes in
and your room isn't tidy.
That's what I feel like.
The first thing I feel
like saying is apologizing.
And then the second thing is like,
whoever has to explain to the guest
that they're gonna be sitting here.
And the first thing you
have to explain to them is
how to get here.
And you're just like, oh, you
just got to go around the set.
- Like you cannot see any of the desks
and we have three desks
over there by the wall.
You can't see any of the desk.
My desk is a fucking war zone
that Maylene's turned to.
- Which was the guest
that thought you had to go under again?
Who was that?
- Raina.
- Oh yeah, Raina.
- I think it was Raina.
- There was so little space.
Raina literally thought that
you had to go under the table.
- Honestly there's probably
more room under the table.
- Probably, probably.
- There's less of a
tripping hazard under here.
- I can't fault her for
thinking that honestly.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, everything, the
way we've done it is all,
it works, but it's literally
the meme of like the Cheeto
holding the door locked.
Everything works, but it's not clean.
It's just about.
It looks good.
I'm happy with how it looks
considering what we've got.
It's the most scuffed
way we can of it looking
as good as it does and
sounding as good as it does.
But yeah, we really wanna upgrade it.
I don't know.
Get a better system in
general just for everything.
Have more guests on, you know,
have guests on "After Dark,"
you know, just having everything upgraded,
everything better, you know.
- You know, it's 'cause of you guys
that we're even able to
fucking move to, you know,
a nicer bigger place.
- Without the Patreon stuff,
we definitely wouldn't be
able to consider the upgrades
that we're doing.
- Absolutely.
- Basically when we started
this podcast, we were just like,
what's the minimum we can get away with
in case this podcast is like zeros,
just crashes and burns immediately, right?
- So, we planned this on
like as much of a budget,
as much money as we were
willing to pay it, essentially.
How much money do we want to lose?
And then also hours do we want to lose?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, I mean, again,
we said this in the previous episode
with the Trash Taste Awards, obviously,
but we're very grateful I think
for the crazy amount of support.
I think if you'd have told
us that we'd be this close
to a million subs after one year,
I think we'd have been like, funny.
- Good joke.
- I'd be like 100,000
subs that's a success.
- We only pushed this channel like what,
twice on our main channels?
Once at the start of the
video or an end of a video,
and then the Akihabura special.
Considering it's everything
else is driven by like Twitter
and you guys just enjoying the show.
- You guys spreading the good word.
- It's crazy, man.
It's crazy to see.
- 'Cause normally with
a lot of podcasts I see,
you have like with big names
and then you have like
the big announcements.
So you've got the big trickle of views.
And then the view just like drips down,
which is what I was expecting.
And I wasn't expecting us to
maintain like the view count.
- For 50 episodes.
- It's also intimidating
'cause now I know that the stuff,
the dumb shit I say it'll be in front of
more people than ever.
- Yeah, one thing I certainly
was surprised by was
just like, just realizing
that some of the shit we say
to each other people,
like hundreds of thousands
of people are now listening
to me.
- I forget about everything I fucking say!
- Same here!
- All the dumb shit.
Like, I got an email
today about baked beans.
Wanted to send me baked beans.
I totally forgot I said
I like baked beans.
And someone's offering to
send me a ton of baked beans,
and I'm like, I'm flattered.
- You can't say no to that.
- I just can't remember why I said this.
I totally forgot.
- Out of context it just sounds
like a random person wanting
to send you baked beans.
- I know I went on a rant
about loving baked beans,
but that was one of those things
where I'm very passionate in the moment
and then when I leave I totally forget
that I had a rant about that.
I did talk very passionately
about baked beans.
That is me.
I did do that.
- I feel that's a lot of moments, right?
I mean, sometimes you just get passionate
when you're talking with your mates
or when you're in like a fucking zakia
or having like an argument
where it's not really an argument,
you're just very passionate in the moment.
- Do you reckon we'll get
any comments people like,
"Man, I like the old set more.
"Had a better vibe to it."
Well, the table's gonna be the same.
- "I stopped watching after season one."
(everyone laughs)
- "Season one is when it went downhill."
- "Season two was a real let down."
I mean, essentially it's
not too much is gonna change really.
- Really, okay, to like
bring down expectations,
really the reason we
want to change offices is
because this is not a
convenient office at all.
On camera we don't want
too much to change.
We just want to work more comfortably
instead of having this like
the most jank fucking set up
for everything we do.
I mean, right now "Trash Taste
After Dark" is running off
of my laptop, okay?
- There's three giant ass HDMIs going
into this man's laptop.
- The cable management is atrocious.
- Literally, it's like, it's
a laptop that's sitting,
that's like hooked up on
like on a foldable chair
that's like connected with wide internet
that's just running in
the middle of the floor.
That's it.
That's "Trash Taste After Dark."
- It is jank as fuck.
- That's because we can't
afford more space right now.
So, it's like the most jank.
- It's mostly for us.
- Enough of us complaining
about all our problems I guess.
Everything should hopefully be better.
We don't know 'cause we haven't moved yet,
but we're hoping that
everything goes really smoothly!
- Offset, I want to shout
out to the Denny's guy.
You're the real G.
(everyone laughs)
- The Denny's guys is always there for us.
- We've talked before about-
- Boss man's always waiting for us.
- We've talked before about how every time
before a "Trash Taste" recording
we have lunch at Denny's,
and we've gone there so often
that there's a guy at Denny's
who knows the exact time we're
coming in on the exact day.
And he knows what we want.
We order the same thing every time.
- He knows how many people as well.
- I've not met a boss man in Japan.
And I hadn't met the boss man
in Japan until I met that guy.
You're a boss man.
(everyone laughs)
- He's a real boss man.
I love it 'cause like
sometimes we would come
into the Denny's and the
moment he sees us, he's like,
"Hey, oh!
"Four, right?
"I got you, I got you.
"I got it reserved for you, don't worry."
- You gonna miss the MILF bar
that's also like next door as well?
So we discovered a bar-
- It's a restaurant.
Just it's ran by a hot woman.
- It's just a restaurant
that's just run by
attractive older Japanese-
- Single MILFs in your area.
- And I remember Connor
first going into there-
- And he had an awakening.
(everyone laughs)
The promised land!
- And then we almost,
we came back almost
every week for a while.
- The land of milk and honey
is right around the corner.
- What a beautiful bar.
- Yeah, I'm gonna miss this area as well.
You know, I didn't have much
expectations for this area.
Obviously we don't-
- We're in a quiet area.
- But like, you know, we've come to,
after a year we've come to
appreciate the small things,
you know.
- We can say we're in, it's whatever.
- Yeah, sure.
- I don't know.
- I mean, I don't think it matters now.
- We're not there anymore.
We're not there anymore.
So we were in Sitomo, but not anymore.
- Commuting was a pain in the ass.
Again, everything was on a budget.
Sitomo's outside of
Tokyo, it's like an hour.
It's an hour away from Tokyo.
- It's immediately cheaper.
- Just close enough that
it kind of feels like it's
in Tokyo.
Kind of like being in zone
four, zone five in London.
- It's like telling your, you know,
the studio is at Heathrow airport.
- It wasn't that far.
It wasn't that far.
- Heathrow airport's like
an hour from central London.
- Yeah, but Tokyo is a
lot bigger as well though,
isn't it? I mean, you can
go from one end of Tokyo
to another in an hour as well.
- I understand these references.
(everyone laughs)
Heathrow, yes.
- Downtown Manhattan, right?
(everyone laughs)
I don't know what I was gonna say.
- Going to Pennsylvania from New York.
- I guess thank you for watching.
Thank you for watching season one.
We don't have much else to say really.
- Hope you guys stick with
us all through season two.
- Look forward to more fun epic-
- There probably won't be a season three
'cause I don't think we plan on upgrading
from the new studio.
- Yeah, it'll be season two for awhile.
(everyone laughs)
- Season one is the test run.
Season two is the one that
has like 500 episodes.
- Don't think there's gonna
be many new plot developments.
- This is literally it.
(everyone laughs)
- Season one was like
the 54 episode pilot.
Season two is where
the actual show begins.
But yeah, hopefully you
guys enjoy the new studio.
- It's like "Arthur."
Does "Arthur" have seasons?
I don't know if "Arthur" has seasons.
- "Arthur?"
- You know what "Arthur" is.
- Oh, you mean the-
- Kid show.
- The cartoon.
- Yeah.
Does that have seasons?
Does "Arthur" have seasons?
I feel like it's just running.
We're gonna be like "Arthur."
We're just never gonna stop airing.
We're just gonna every single week.
- I never heard of anyone being like,
"Oh, season 23 of Arthur was my favorite."
- I don't know.
Does "Arthur" have seasons?
Can you Google it?
"Arthur" doesn't have seasons.
It just runs.
It just keeps going.
- It just runs.
- I'd say it's more like
"Come Dine With Me" right?
- Which we're just gonna keep
coming and coming every week.
We come every week, guys.
"Trash Taste" comes every week.
- Come!
Now.
(everyone laughs)
- That's it, we'll see you guys next.
- No, we gotta shout out the Patrons.
- Look at these lovely Patrons.
- Look at these Patrons
who come every week.
- Whom without we could
not move into a new studio
and have a better setup
than we do now off screen.
- [Maylene] "Arthur" has seasons.
- No, it doesn't.
Fuck off.
- [Man] Season 22.
- Season 22!
- That's basically one season.
- One long season 22.
- I don't even, I can't tell.
- Hey, if you like "Arthur" season 22,
then make sure to go over to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
And also go subscribe to "After Dark."
There's gonna be a lot more
content there hopefully.
- Hopefully.
- Starting very soon though.
- Yeah.
- Bye, old studio.
- Yeah bye.
- Bye, old studio!
I mean, we're taking most of this with us.
I mean, I'm taking with me.
- What were you gonna say, Garnt,
before I rudely interrupted you?
- I have no idea.
- Fantastic.
- All right, see you
guys in the new studio!
Bye!
- That was like our slowest outro ever.
What the fuck is that?
(chill music plays)